mobile task force Edna 84 also known by the code
name and thus upon his Crucible is on one of the
strangest missions they've ever been sent on they
sit in a darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer monitors
shine upon their faces they're tackling a monster
that if it escapes will literally devour all of
creation it has no fear it has no remorse and if
it isn't kept contained by Edna 84 it may escape
and wreak havoc across the world oh and did we
mention it's trapped in a Minecraft server you
heard us right scp-4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extra-dimensional being of pure Terror trapped
inside a procedurally generated world in the
immensely popular game Minecraft you hear about
a lot of horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is Minecraft
in there's a lot that needs explaining here
and we intend to get to all of it but let's
start with how the foundation keeps This truly
exceptional Beast contained the foundation first
discovered scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
Alpha version of Minecraft was released because
of the online nature of the game it's proven to
be impossible to contain 4335 externally seeing
as it isn't confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in is
not an effective containment method either as
this just causes the entity to Simply hop to
a different server the foundation's greatest
fear is that 4335 will one day make the leap
out of Minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft containment
procedures for scp-4335 within the game this led
to the creation of a containment site unlike any
other site M1 the first official Foundation site
made entirely out of Minecraft blocks everyone
who was originally involved in the server has
been removed and anistatized since then a lead
SCP Foundation containment Specialists and Gamers
have been constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335 side M1 is a large Stone complex built
into the side of a mountain it has a number of
key features including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335's continued containment
chests filled with books that contain scp-4335's
containment procedures a few animal farms for
the purpose of breeding and killing livestock
for their meat the entrance to a mine several
chests containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335 if they ever
breach containment and enter the server and of
course the actual containment chamber for scp-4335
itself which is a little more complicated 4335's
containment chamber is built out of several layers
all made from iron blocks the outermost cube is 75
by 75 by 75 blocks the inner cube is 55 by 55
by 55 blocks and the innermost cube is 25 by 25
by 25 blocks creating several levels of Defense
finally one layer within all these others which
contains the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks scp-4335 is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex mechanism the
outermost cube is completely filled with water and
several dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount of time
line the cube the cube also contains several mob
Farms which are devices that constantly spawn
enemies into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially designed
to funnel a constant flow of items inwards to
scp-4335 there are even contingency measures for
if scp-4335 manages to breach in containment if
Escape is attempted blocks of TNT detonate above
the ceiling causing lava to pour into the chamber
at that point MTF Edna 84 are dispatched into the
server to lure 4335 back into its containment
chamber to do this they fire a mix of fire
resistant potions and ender pearls which have
teleportation capabilities interestingly there's
one more basic method of luring scp-4335 back
into the obsidian Cube taunting and insulting
one of scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the screen
and being a proud creature it often responds
to insults by charging in to directly Engage
The insulter if scp-4335 still manages to breach
the containment that has been set up for it then
they even expect that it will likely soon hop into
another server at that point the goal will shift
to finding the monster and re-containing it with
containment procedures this complex and extensive
it shouldn't come as a surprise that scp-4335
rests firmly in the ketter class what exactly
is this anomalous entity why does its containment
hinge on constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in Mojang's popular building and
survival game in the first place scp-4335 in terms
of physical dimensions appears almost identical
to the player character with an all black skin
it also appears to be constantly shrouded
in a cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back in some
respects 4335 has been compared to two popular
Creepypasta figures Herobrine and the Slenderman
but 4335 is far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the game
with a few peculiar anomalous abilities we'll
discuss soon handling scp-4335 is an extremely
delicate process us if command blocks creative
mode or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with scp-4335 the server will instantly
shut down and scp-4335 will move to a different
server scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to destroy
surrounding blocks before consuming them with each
successful consumption scp-4335 grows and when it
reaches sufficient size it hops to a different
server as you can see keeping scp-4335 contained
is an uphill battle but luckily there are two
factors on the foundation side here the first
is that scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to actively
Escape Foundation forces the second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between consuming
blocks in order to grow meaning if its consumption
is constant and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the entirety of
the foundation's containment procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber and fed
items and blocks constantly effectively rooting
it in place when scp-4335 begins to grow the
foundation also found that the application of
Ender Pearls helps reduce it back to its normal
size however scp-4335 does have a method of
striking back against its captors 4335 is a virgin
class multi-sensory Cognito Hazard anyone viewing
it without proper training and protection may
experience distressing hallucinations scp-4335
is also capable of telepathic speech with people
playing on its server and as we alluded to earlier
it can also hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when it comes
to scps considering it's pretty much a requirement
for the foundation to take interest in you but
the null devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is strange even by
Foundation standards MTF Edna 84 first discovered
scp-4335 in the single-player server of Minecraft
user leaking heart three team members Jason yelsen
Richard Duchamp and Shelia Freemason covertly
entered the game to investigate and potentially
apprehend the creature when leaking Hart first
discovered their presence on what he thought
was a private server he quickly left a little
creeped out by the sudden intrusion thankfully
the trio was still able to locate scp-4335 they
discovered the creature hiding inside a giant
crater as though it had impacted the Earth at
considerable speed Richard Duchamp who is
the leader of the team at the time made the
mistake of looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of scp-4335's
Cognito hazardous effects he hallucinated
believing that his keyboard was melting before
his eyes in the aftermath of this incident Duchamp
was taken off the case and Jason yelson was
promoted to head of the project things were still
going to get stranger Yeltsin was able to open a
dialogue with the creature after containing it in
a chamber filled with lava it asked him whether it
had landed in the right location meaning our world
and yelson informed him that it somehow fallen
into the world of Minecraft instead the creature
was at first confused and then angry and resentful
about its situation it vowed to find its way into
our world somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to breach
containment and hop into another server Yeltsin
and two others once again managed to track
it down and recontain it but this time two
civilians also inhabiting the server were exposed
to the anomalous effects of scp-4335 they weren't
heard but they did appear strange and incoherent
after experiencing 4335's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the aftermath and
gave them amnestic treatment 4335 was contained
shortly thereafter once again Yeltsin came face to
face with his new phone eight months after being
captured 4335 granted Yeltsin another interview
from containment 4335 admitted that it almost
respected Yeltsin and the rest of the foundation
for figuring out how to capture and contain it so
quickly in exchange it would give the foundation
something extremely valuable information first
it asked one question of yelson how does he
Define creation yosin replied uh something
that is built and brought into this universe
by a Sapient being using other things from
this universe 4335 agreed it went on to explain
that it came from a universe devoid of creation
a dark and unknowable place filled with nothing
but violent random chaos its Dimension existed
directly above ours and it often looked down at
us through a dimensional window fascinated by
all the creation below it plotted and dreamed to
one day infiltrate our reality and yes and finally
had the opportunity to ask the magic question
why though he wasn't quite ready for the brutal
honesty of scp-4335's reply I do not like to lie
so I will tell you now I wish to suck it dry of
the toys of whatever Force controls your Universe
destroy the light destroy the Earth and Destroy
Humanity it reminded me of me a blubbering mass
of intelligence and order it sickens me in ways I
cannot comprehend I hope you understand scp-4335
was a connoisseur of creation and it sought to
devour all of it in this moment Yeltsin realized
what an incredibly dangerous entity he was dealing
with the only mystery was why this creature
had somehow landed in Minecraft instead of our
which appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but Yeltsin didn't have time to think 4335 was
about to Stage another daring escape attempt
one of its tendrils reached out and attacked
yelson's player character in that moment the
real-life yelson began to hallucinate and panic
suddenly back in the game a series of abnormally
tall slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber around
scp-4335 it had somehow summoned new minions into
the game to assist in this Containment Breach
Jason yelson entered Cognito Hazard quarantine
following this incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one affected by
this incident following the first appearance of
these long dark figures players across the globe
began to experience them appearing in their own
games the foundation managed to find a solution
they contacted Mojang and had the creatures
patched into the game during the next update
as a new non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as its own
tools they're now known as the Enderman and are
beloved among fans for being one of the creepier
enemies to this day containment efforts continue
for scp-4335 but there's only one question left
why did The Entity fall into Minecraft rather than
our world the file posits the most likely answer
because 4335 defines creation as elements made
by Sapient beings in Minecraft the most popular
game in the world at the height of 4335's power
everything that exists is the product of code
made by humans creation is truly abundant there
as for our world in scp-4335's extra dimensional
eyes there is no Nation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just frightening chaotic
Randomness which is too unlike its own Dimension
so even if scp-4335 ever did arrive in our reality
it would likely be disappointed by how little
there is to eat have you ever seen something you
weren't supposed to something that made you feel
off something you regret Secrets like these are
Best Kept to yourself but since you're still alive
whatever you saw wasn't nearly as bad as what
Peter Holland saw one fateful night in January
of 2015. Peter was an unremarkable man an office
worker slaving away at The Daily Grind and like
a lot of people Peter enjoyed nothing more than
coming home after a long hard day kicking back
and watching some TV it was this innocent activity
that led to Peter's horrifying brush with scp-5049
altering the course of his otherwise average life
forever the event started at around 1005 PM
Peter was channel surfing glued to the couch
in his sparsely furnished apartment commercials
commercials commercials as far as Peter's tired
eyes could see he paused for a moment to watch
the end of an ad for a car he could never hope
to afford on his salary but something stopped
him from changing the channel again the next ad
had begun and it was playing a strange scratchy
jingle that gave Peter an odd sense of unease
but even Stranger Than That was the text on screen
demon Dan's Discount homunculus Depot in baby blue
bubble lettering he forced a smile this had to be
some weird comedy skit or viral marketing campaign
or maybe it was something he drank but no this
was a real commercial and things were about to get
even weirder the Pepe logo faded to a concerning
site a tall humanoid figure dressed like a used
car salesman but one that definitely wasn't human
his skin was dark green and covered in patches of
thick fur he had long fingers with intimidating
Claws and a grin full of needle-like fangs it
looked almost demonic and after a few seconds
the demon began to speak hey there folks it's
a man demon Dan coming at you with the latest
and greatest deals from demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot we've just accepted a shipment
of brand new models that would make even the most
Discerning customers went with excitement let's
see what we've got the creature apparently named
demon Dan stepped away from his desk revealing two
long furry goat legs that ended in large pointed
Hooves Peter now assumed he really was going crazy
but at this point he was along for the ride demon
Dan continued his pitch looking to make your way
through the capitalist hellscape that makes home
look cozy come try one of our newest businessman
models Dan gestured behind him to where Peter was
horrified to see a total of 52 adult male human
bodies hanging from a wall there was something
uncanny about them they seemed almost Hollow like
a highly realistic costume or a prop from a horror
movie Peter didn't have much time to think
about it though as demon Dan went on if your
if your challenge of inequality the businesswoman
model may be a right fit for you the commercial
then revealed a wall of human female bodies
strung up in a similar fashion now you may
be thinking but and business sounds hot I just
want to have some fun and the fine team here at
demon Dan's Discount homunculus Depot have got you
covered the camera zoomed out to show an area of
the store filled with children's decorations
and more of these strange hollowed-out human
suits in child sizes to match and kids no one
limiters of any child size unit comes with a
with a sent off coupon for parental units you
just can't say no to a deal like that before
Peter could process the madness that was unfolding
before him the camera cut again the store's logo
appeared on the screen once more along with
several cuts to locations around the store
itself there are more human bodies hundreds of
them demon Dan's sleazy voice rang out over all
of it here I demon dance discount homunculus
Depot we know it's not all fun and games the
brightest Among Us have a mission to accomplish
the seven Lords are ever planning their Invasion
after all so you're looking for function over form
well we've got that in Spades down here in the
Tactical Services Department you'll be kicking Us
in no time when you're wearing the latest models
at the best prices seven Lords Invasion what did
any of this mean suddenly the camera was showing
him a new room red curtains parted revealing
more of these person suits several bearing a
striking resemblance to real human celebrities
he managed to make out Gucci Mane Avril Lavigne
Paul McCartney and Britney Spears before demon
Dan's appearance once again drew his attention
I've got a special treat for you we're happy to
announce the VIP look-alike Department we all
know how difficult the creation of homunculus is
it's a fine art that takes years of practice so
when a replacement order on VIPs comes in every
detail needs to be perfect unfortunately really
that's not always the case but for the right
price you too can look like famous icons from
around the globe the image of celebrity bodies
faded from View and Peter was left looking at
the grinning demon Dan standing behind the front
desk of his impossible store once more he said
there you have it folks come on down to demon
dance discount homunculus Depot if you're viewing
the advertisement then you've been selected for
entry please enter the nearest door for instant
deals and upgrade those old Duds for one of our
newest models what are you waiting for come on
down the logo popped up again hovering above some
bold text that said please enter the nearest door
Peter had had enough he switched off the TV what
a horror show he thought they should just warn you
before they put short horror films on TV like
that he had no idea they could just slip them
in among regular commercials Shirley demon Dan in
this store couldn't be real right but as his eyes
drifted to the door in his room he didn't feel
feel quite so certain well there was only one
way to find out Peter got up went over to the
door took a deep breath and walked through it
Peter Holland was never seen again not as himself
anyway the SCP Foundation has long been aware of
this Sinister transmission known as scp-5049-2
and luckily has found ways to prevent it from
claiming more victims the foundation television
analysis Department as well as web crawler 40y
40 which is the software the foundation uses to
root out anomalous activity online are always
vigilant for signs of demon Dan's commercial
running just observing demon Dan who is himself
classified as scp-5049-a and his ads put you in
immediate danger as they can transform any nearby
doors into scp-5049-1s those are interdimensional
portals that remain active for around 15 minutes
after viewing the ad so then what specifically is
scp-5049 it's the entire pocket Dimension known as
demon Dan's Discount homunculus Depot a cutie or
class spatial anomaly constantly on the lookout
for new human victims which it transforms into
fleshy suits for its demonic clients which let
them blend in around humans prior to its Discovery
by the foundation it's likely that demon Dan and
his associates claimed hundreds if not thousands
of lives but sadly even discovering this anomaly
came at a gruesome cost to the foundation on
February 16 2020 the ad played on safe storage
Warehouse 13's break room television at the time
of the broadcast four Foundation Personnel were
present including security agent William Birkin
worrying that this was a potential security threat
agent Birkin investigated the door to a nearby
closet the second he opened it he was transformed
to the storefront of demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot he saw demon Dan himself standing
at the corner while four smaller reptilian Ms
fought over a small flesh suit demon Dan scolded
them before turning his attention to agent Perkin
does testis you aren't supposed to be here little
man how naughty I'm gonna have to have a word
with marketing once I'm through with you agent
Burkin fearing for his safety drew his weapon
and shot demon damn three times the creature
dematerialized before appearing right next to
agent Birkin and disarming him with a swift chop
the unfortunate security agent was then grabbed by
the considerably larger demon Dan and thrown over
Dan's shoulder we know all of this because agent
birkin's standard issue Foundation body camera
recorded the whole terrifying ordeal even as demon
Dan dragged the helpless Birkin back into the
Twisted Workshop behind the store there Birkin saw
what would soon be his own fate right before his
eyes Dan's minions converting human bodies into
fleshy suits for their demon clientele and this
unfortunate security officer was next Dan gave him
over to a pair of large sheep like demons and told
them to drain skin and declaw him birkin's video
feed finally cut as the demons pulled out the
rusty tools and began to work on him of course the
SCP Foundation wouldn't take an attack on one of
their operatives inside one of their facilities no
less lying down the unfortunate death of William
Birkin allowed the foundation to refine their
methods of intercepting the broadcast of demon
Dan's commercials they even had a new mobile Task
Force Mobile Strike Force Kappa 11 or the Baphomet
Bashers specifically to deal with demon Dan and
his cronies they did more than just prevent him
from taking new humans though when the Baphomet
Bashers teamed up with an A-Class Clairvoyant
entity to improve their efficiency in predicting
future broadcasts they were able to launch sting
operations and arrest 21 different demonic
customers for interrogation this impressive
strike back finally gave the foundation some
meaningful leverage over demon Dan and through
the use of their Clairvoyant entity they were able
to call a temporary truce and arrange a meeting
with demon Dan himself Captain Steiner an agent
of the foundation external negotiation Department
was the one to interrogate demon Dan they sat
across from each other at a table and Demon Dan
was clearly tense frustrated with the way the
foundation had been messing with his business
all of their sting operations were frightening off
his customers in return for letting him continue
his work the foundation wanted Dan to turn over
all the information on his bosses and customers
allowing the foundation to track their movements
when Dan was evasive about whether he'd comply
they tried threatening him Dan laughed them
off go ahead take your best shot little man
there's a dozen more just like me you won't stop
anything finally he was pressured into giving a
yes or no answer as to whether he'd willingly
collaborate with the foundation and act as an
informant against his kind when demon Dan hinted
that he may be willing to comply he began to make
a horrifying gurgling noise and gripped his head
in pain he began speaking in Latin in a voice that
wasn't his own as though the seven demon Lords he
served were speaking through him they said you are
a fool Jailer to think a pathetic morso such as
this could Aid you against us I have allowed you
to toil in your own delusions for far too long
you may have taken advantage of azimodius all
those years ago but you stop nothing You Hinder
nothing you jail and barter to no avail your time
is coming and then demon Dan's head exploded
which obviously prevented him from giving any
incriminating information on those he worked for
whoever the demon Lords are there's certainly the
secretive type you may think that this is the end
of Demon dance discount homunculus Depot and of
scp-5049 but soon another ad ran it advertised
the same products and services out of the same
store the only difference was that this time
a different entity was starring in it it was
July of 2004 and Bill Murray was enjoying
the peak of an extremely successful career
not only had the iconic actors starred in
some of the most beloved comedies of the
20th century including Ghostbusters and Groundhog
Day he'd voiced the main character of the recently
released live-action Garfield movie it'd been a
financial success but it was a critical flop not
that this bothered Bill he was happy with the
performance and the paycheck what he wouldn't
be quite as happy about was the horrifying
encounter he was about to have with scp-3166
on July 8th bill was enjoying a cold drink on
the porch of his luxurious Beverly Hills Home
the sky was beginning to darken as the sun
set in the west it was a blissful evening
his wife Jennifer was inside watching TV nothing
seemed particularly out of the ordinary until he
noticed a quick flash of orange in the distance
it was almost too fast to register this large
orange-shaped darting past the corner of his eye
for a second he entertained the thought that it
might have been an escaped Tiger but it was gone
too fast to really tell Bill finished his drink
and headed inside he had enough for one night
the next morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting slaughtered
by the critics one review stated no one can
accuse Garfield the movie of infidelity to its
source it Faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film without
energy and without spirit you put the paper down
and ate his breakfast a few blows to the ego
were worth it for the paydays that came with
big budget family films just then his wife came
to him with a strange question were you walking
around downstairs in the middle of the night no
he hadn't he'd been sleeping like a baby why did
she ask well Jennifer said I heard some rustling
downstairs last night it sounded like something
big he hadn't heard anything though and told her
it was probably just Her Imagination he put it out
of his mind and continued about his day he decided
he would keep his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though Bill didn't see anything peculiar the
rest of the morning and went to a local cafe for
lunch he ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the bathroom
while his food was prepared when Bill returned
to his table though there was something strange
instead of a bagel there was a large heaping of
lasagna on the table what was going on this Cafe
didn't even serve lasagna Bill knew something was
terribly wrong things only got stranger when bill
came home to find a small tuft of orange fur
snagged on the frame of his front door and it
wasn't synthetic for her like you'd see on plush
toys or stuffed animals no this was real animal
fur maybe someone was just goofing off or trying
to play some weird prank on him but it didn't feel
like it deep down Bill Murray knew that he was in
grave danger whoever or whatever was behind this
it wanted to hurt him that night his worst fears
were realized Bill's wife had left town for the
week and he was headed to the kitchen in the
middle of the night for a glass of water when
he saw something a huge figure moving up against
the glass door leading to his backyard the thing
was huge nearly seven feet tall with a bloated
fur-covered misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright garish orange
a cartoon or strangest of all though was the sound
it was making it sounded like it was purring Bill
backed away from the door and then ran back to his
room to hide the whole night he sat cowering
as he heard scratching against the walls like
something was trying to get in he was terrified
and too scared to do anything even move finally
as morning broke the noises seemed to stop Bill
had to do something he couldn't let this nightmare
go on another night what if things got worse what
if that thing managed to get inside he called the
local police and when they arrived he explained
the incredibly strange situation as best he could
he told them he was being stalked by some kind of
huge cat or at least someone dressed like a huge
cat also there was lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain their
laughter as he told them his story a giant orange
cat perhaps one of them theorized he angered
some kind of obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the live-action movie after all
the original comic had been running for years and
had been extremely popular who knows what kind of
nut jobs were obsessed with seeing only a fateful
adaptation of the source material as the officers
departed bill was confident that they weren't
taking him seriously he couldn't rely on any of
them for protection thankfully from a multi-decade
movie career he had plenty of disposable income
and decided to hire a private security team to
protect him while he looked into this mystery
he had two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month they
were armed and given the cryptic orders to fire on
anything orange meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down
A Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt strangely compelled
to research all the Garfield media he could find
as though the answer to his terrifying situation
was somehow hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic strips
he read the books and interviews with Jim Davis he
watched the cartoons and straight to DVD animated
movies ironically for a guy who'd recently
trade the lasagna loving orange cat Bill had never
felt quite so immersed in the character before
he found the strange Pathos in the routine of
Garfield and his friends one particular comic
really piqued his interest though originally
published in October of 1989 the comic began
with Garfield being woken up by a strange Chell
and almost Eerie sensation the character observed
aloud that he didn't feel like he was in his own
home he explored his little home further trying to
find his owner John or his housemate and sometimes
Nemesis Odie but found nothing as Garfield
remarked on feeling alone a purple speechbox
delivered the Sinister message you have no
idea how alone you are Garfield he then finds that
his home looks like it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically ancient
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying Revelation
everyone really is God in his adventures and
friends now exist only in his imagination
he's trapped in a prison of his own creation
trying to Stave off his endless loneliness
in denial about the reality of his situation the
comic ended with a quote directly from Jim Davis
himself saying an imagination is a powerful tool
it content memories of the past shade perceptions
of the present or paint a future so vivid that
it can entice or terrify all depending upon how
we conduct ourselves today as he read those words
Bill Murray felt a chill down his spine why had
he wanted to get involved in the Garfield movie
in the first place what had he gotten himself
into before he could slip any deeper into his own
mind Bill heard a faint choked scream downstairs
he felt his breath catch in his throat he was
terrified but needed to see what was happening
carefully and quietly began to creep down the
stairs at the bottom he poked his head around
a corner and that's when he saw a member of
his security detail lying dead on the floor
his face was Blue from asphyxiation
his mouth was stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to death
they wanted to scream but he couldn't or maybe
knew he shouldn't just then he heard a soft
meaty thumping noise coming from the nearby
living room he didn't know why but he felt
compelled to approach as if by forces Beyond
his control he made his way to the living room
and when he'd got there he saw where the noise
was coming from Bill's jaw dropped in pure horror
there was the other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant orange
figure who was a grotesquely huge creature
wearing what looked to be a kind of crude Garfield
outfit made of sewn together cat palettes it's
stank of pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held the golden trophy which it was using to
pound the security guard's head into mush while
making quiet cat-like purring noises the creature
suddenly stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he froze as
the giant freakish Garfield stepped over Donny's
corpse and began to come towards him bill turned
and ran but Garfield was gaining on him before
he could make it to the front door the creature
knocked him over he was laid out on the ground
looking up at it as it reached into its own body
cavity and began to pull out handfuls of lasagna
he was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when suddenly a
ding Was Heard and the creature stopped looked up
as if sniffing the air and then suddenly turned
and lumbered towards the kitchen Bill watched
as the Garfield monster entered the kitchen
where somehow there was a steaming hot fresh
lasagna sitting in the open oven the creature had
sensed the presence of external lasagna and felt
the compulsion to integrate it into its body
grabbing fistfuls and shoving it into itself
just then a group of highly trained SCP Foundation
Personnel burst into the room and subdued the
creature had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the creature
by monitoring the local police department
dispatches and the report of a seven foot
tall comic book CAD terrorizing a Hollywood actor
was definitely worth looking into the monster that
had almost taken Bill Murray's life was scp-3166 a
deadly pathophysical being that tends to manifest
around people somehow involved in the Garfield
intellectual property it appears whenever the
public perception of Garfield falls out of favor
and because Bill had starred in the critically pan
Garfield movie he was currently at the very top
of scp-3166's Hit List thankfully he managed to
survive his terrifying ordeal and was administered
amnestics by Foundation Personnel so that he could
return to his normal life this frightening and
mysterious creature has been around since 1989
appearing after the publication of The Haunting
Garfield comic that Bill had read that very night
it appeared in the office of United media who
were the Publishers of the Garfield comic strip
at the time and began wrecking Havoc since
then the creature's manifestation has been
a constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result the
foundation has spent years as the funding
source behind all Garfield media and even
planting hypnotic mimetics into the comic strips
to ensure that there is always a loyal fan base
the fur is indeed real organic cat fur albeit an
unnaturally orange color and instead of organs
the creature is filled with lasagna worst of all
though is that testing has revealed that the meat
in the lasagna is genetically identical to the
Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim Davis how did
this thing come into existence perhaps it was
Jim's sheer force of imagination that dragged
it into being as he himself said an imagination
is a powerful tool all in all it's lucky that
Bill Murray was able to survive his encounter
and return to his normal life well as normal as
life can be for Bill Murray and if you see Bill
Murray don't bother asking him about scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and just as
he's fond of saying himself no one will ever
believe you your new SCP Foundation researcher
on tour of site 17 familiarizing yourself with
the location and its many anomalous inhabitants
it's the second largest Foundation containment
site out there and it's also the kind of job
that most Junior researchers dream of low-risk
humanoid containment baby most of the inhabitants
in your sector are cordial willing to comply with
orders from staff and seeing for all intents and
purposes pretty much human you pass from door to
door looking through the viewing hatch of each
one you can't believe what you're seeing it's
a wonderful who's who of anomalous humanoids you
see the wise bearded face of scp-343 known to some
as God you see the blue eyes and Shining blonde
hair of Iris as cp105 looking wistfully into a
Polaroid picture you see the tanned melancholic
face of Kane scp-073 as he stares off into the
middle distance face after face after face passes
you can see yourself getting more familiar with
each one yes your time here will be wait was
that Hitler you stop and walk back to the door
you just passed where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him it's got to be him
you recognize the unpleasant sneer the Hideous
comb over the silly little toothbrush mustache
the SCP Foundation seems to have Adolf Hitler
the former leader of the Third Reich in World
War II in active containment and his designation
is scp-2430 you've seen Killer toasters and masks
that can take over people's minds but you've never
seen anything as surreal as this you immediately
run to your Superior and ask how and why Hitler is
in one of the site-17 humanoid containment cells
Buckle in because we can guarantee it's one of the
most insane stories you've ever heard it's late
April 1945 and the Soviets are rampaging through
Nazi Germany destroying everything in their path
the German forces have been nearly obliterated and
Hitler and the rest of his Reich chancellory have
retreated to a secure bunker beneath Berlin there
on April 30th 10 days after his 56th birthday
Hitler died this was truly unfortunate for the
Soviets as they wish to have had the chance to
kill him themselves two days later Soviet forces
stormed the fury bunker it was little more than a
formality at that point as the news of Hitler's
death had already gone public by the time they
arrived all that was left of Hitler was a pile of
mostly burned remains A fitting end for someone
who had caused the same cruel fate for so many
others they collected what was left of Hitler's
body and brought it back to the Fatherland
a kind of trophy for their Nation but Hitler
dying before Joseph Stalin could get his hands
on him was not what Stalin wanted Hitler had not
only caused the deaths of millions of Russians
he had personally betrayed Stalin's trust and
when you betray Stalin bad things happen to you
very very bad things two years earlier in 1943
Soviet forces had raided the camp in genowiska
belonging to the obscura Corps think of them as
the Nazi's own version of the SCP Foundation who
were hell-bent on Gathering anomalous people and
artifacts to increase the power of the Third Reich
they were a far more militant offshoot of the tool
Society a group that described itself as a study
group for Germanic Antiquity while this may seem
innocent the Teo Society was actually a racist
cult closely aligned with the goals and ideas
of the German Nazi party many have also speculated
that they were heavily involved in the occult and
it's this mysticism obsessed offshoot that went on
to form the obscura corpse and in their janowaska
base they'd obtained a hundred pieces of Enchanted
occult flesh with human skeletons embedded in each
of them this flesh was believed to originate
from the mythological surimner the Beast hunted
and eaten again and again by the pantheon of
Norse gods having the qualities of both a wild
boar and the Goat the flesh can bond to skeletons
and give them a quality somewhat like immortality
any flesh cut from them will regrow time and time
again if given a rest period now that he had both
the Flesh of surimner and Hitler's burnt remains
Stalin had an idea a perfect way to not only
bring satisfaction to the Russian people and the
world but to finally exact the true Revenge that
Hitler had denied to him he called it project
judica namely after the very bottom level of
Hell reserved for betrayers like Judas a perfect
tribute for an old Ally turned enemy he couldn't
kill Hitler before but if Stalin was going to get
the chance Hitler needed to live again for years
Stalin's top scientists try to use Arcane methods
to resurrect Hitler by combining his remains with
the Flesh of suramir at times they even came
close to creating a new Hitler but there was
one huge issue the creature they created could not
feel pain and for Stalin's plans of violent and
painful retribution the lack of suffering simply
would not do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing board Stalin would
stop at nothing to get what he wanted even if it
meant breaking every law of nature in the process
in order to make his Twisted dream a reality Stahl
informed an Unholy alliance with a group known
as the uralic fleshcrafters a neo-sarkic cult
that was a branch of the nightmarish religion
of sarcasism this group essentially worships
avatars of Flesh corruption and disease and are
behind some of the most terrifying and disgusting
anomalies out there including the flesh that hates
and the bone Orchard true sarcasists who show the
proper Devotion to their vile deities and know the
right rituals to contact them are often granted
anomalous powers that spread the sarkic influence
further across the known Dimensions these Powers
will usually involve having a supernatural ability
to manipulate the Flesh of themselves and others
allowing them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies Beyond repair they can
sometimes even create life if they're a powerful
enough acolyte of psychicism and it was because of
these powers that Stalin wanted the erolic flesh
Crafters under his command in exchange for their
participation he would give them a vast quantity
of the Flesh of suramir which they could use for
their own Sinister sarkic purposes a deal was
struck and the true work of resurrecting Hitler
began Stalin was very specific in his requirements
he gave the uralic fleshcrafters extra bones to
compensate for what had gone missing from
Hitler's burnt remains he also gave them
samples of the Flesh of saramir to achieve the
desired effects of a near Immortal tolerance for
damage however Stalin demanded that he heightened
this new Hitler's capacity to experience pain
so that every suffering inflicted on him would
be three times worse than anyone else and true
to their word the flesh Crafters got to work and
began creating just such a creature by now it
was the early 1950s and Stalin was putting the
pieces in place for his Grand Revenge once the
new Hitler was finished he would hold a new
trial for him in the Russian courts where he
would preside over the sentencing personally once
the new Hitler was done the uralic fleshcrafters
were rewarded for their participation in Project
Utica with four thousand kilograms of the Flesh
of saramir Stalin now had his very own personal
Hitler chew toy that he could maim and torture
as much as he pleased knowing that he would always
heal and soon be ready for more in their infinite
generosity the fleshcrafters even taught Stalin a
new method of Torment for his old enemy a process
known as the right of nyas it's a torture that's
been described by many as being like the Chinese
Ling Chi also known as the linger during death
or slow slicing but it is probably best known
as the death by a Thousand Cuts the Soviets and
the sarkix parted ways for the next few years
Stalin took a great deal of pleasure in visiting
Hitler's cage now and then to torture him until
Stalin himself eventually passed away from natural
causes the grup division which is essentially the
Soviet answer to the SCP Foundation decided
it would be best to do away with the immortal
Hitler clone after Stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how hard they
tried they couldn't permanently kill him either
in the end they settled on a kind of compromise
he would be buried alive and forgotten forced
to live a torturous eternity that he could never
Escape until of course he was dug up and rescued
by none other than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura corpse like
many high-profile Nazis who'd escaped the war the
new Hitler was Spirited Away to a safe house run
by sympathizers in Arjun Tina the ones taking care
of him received the following correspondence from
the obscura agents who'd first dug the new Hitler
back up they have managed to rescue zafira and
bring him to safety but he is effectively dead
on the inside I blames the Reds for their inhumane
treatment of zafira who may have been Bewitched by
zerez vandavath a wish we could merciful him but
we've tried everything he just won't perish don't
abandon him he's too distinct in plain sight they
didn't have the new Hitler for long though in 1960
efforts to hunt down the remaining Nazi fugitives
increased in intensity the new Hitler was soon
captured by Mossad agents searching for Nazis in
Buenos Aires and then remanded to the containment
of the SCP Foundation when they realized that he
had a number of anomalous properties such as his
incredible regenerative abilities as well as the
fact that his DNA seems to be based on that of a
wild boar and a goat rather than a human however
x-rays conducted by the foundation have discovered
traces of cyanide still in his system system as
well as traces of lead in his skull where the
bone has regrown over the bullet in other words
it was unquestionably the real Hitler and he was
now in Foundation custody forevermore it's such a
wild story even by Foundation standards that you
can barely summon the words to respond once your
supervisor is finished he just stands there with
a slight smile basking in your amazement before
you can even ask again he confirms the facts one
more time yes it is the real Hitler the only
functional difference is that he can't die and
he has a heightened sense of pain compared to most
people you think on what you've been told for just
a moment and then you have only one question are
we allowed to punch him your supervisor smiles and
says of course we all do feeling hungry maybe
you could go for a snack right about now or a
nice refreshing can of your favorite soda perhaps
if you've got some change burning a hole in your
pocket a nearby vending machine would be a good
choice and trust us there's no vetting machine
like this one scp-261 will give you a treat that's
out of this world or rather out of this Dimension
that's how this safe class anomaly earned its
incredibly accurate name the interdimensional
vending machine it was first discovered in a dark
alley in Yokohama Japan Japan is a place where you
can find a number of strange and surprising things
in vending machines but nothing quite like this
the foundation was first alerted to its presence
after one of their web trawlers noticed some
interesting chatter on Japanese online message
boards about a magic vending machine to these
Japanese form users it sounded like a fanciful
urban legend a vending machine where you could get
something truly Fantastical if you have the yen to
spare but upon thorough investigation field agents
of the SCP Foundation discovered that the machine
was no Legend and brought it into containment it's
the kind of thing you wouldn't look twice at an
utterly generic black vending machine machine
with no viewing window and a handwritten sign
in Japanese that reads out of order but what
the vending machine looks like isn't nearly
as interesting as what it's capable of when
you insert your money into the machine and it's
important to note that it only accepts Japanese
Yen the machine will dispense some kind of snack
food or drink item however over time the more the
machine is used in a single day the more bizarre
the items it spits out will become Foundation
researchers have attempted to figure out how the
machine works but their task has been incredibly
difficult so far it doesn't appear to contain
any snacks and it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine simply won't
work when the front panel is opened or when any
surveillance equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to look this
gift horse in the mouth strangely the machine is
also capable of working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely to become
strain danger much faster but let's be honest here
you're not here for vending machine mechanics 101
you want to hear about all the weird stuff that
scp-261 dispenses and frankly we're with you on
that one lucky for all of us this is one of the
anomalies that the foundation has truly extensive
test records on providing us with a highlight rail
of some of the strangest wildest and downright
most interesting snacks and drinks straight out
of another dimension Bon Appetit let's start
off nice and easy with some of the snacks and
drinks that are not only edible but also sound
like they'd actually be pretty tasty like Pepsi
Dragon twist a bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit PepsiCo
does not produce such a product but honestly we
wish they did same for Dark Side Cola a clear
liquid that becomes jet black shortly after being
open which apparently tastes like your average can
of coke with the Touch of Spice thrown in but hey
not everybody likes Cola maybe you're a Maverick
a rebel only a soft drink with a formal title
can quench your thirst and as such you prefer
Dr Pepper in which case maybe the vending machine
will furnish you with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as Dr Pepper's amusing straw this
spatial anomaly wrapped inside a Whimsical Dr
Pepper branded straws seems to contain far more
liquid than should be able to fit in the straw
about one bottle's worth of soda to be precise
a nice and convenient solution for whenever you
need to get the fix that only an accredited doctor
of popology can provide and if you fancy something
from the more intoxicating end of the beverage
Spectrum for 600 Yen you can get yourself a
rare bottle of Billy beer it's just the thing
for those who weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try brew that
was endorsed by the younger brother of President
Jimmy Carter this anomalous bottle of Suds which
was bottled in the 1970s according to its label
came with a note reading I had this beer brewed
just for me I I think it's the best I've ever
tasted and I've tasted a lot I think you'd like it
too Billy Carter drinking the beer got a d-class
intoxicated for 72 hours but what if you've
just wet your whistle and worked up a hunger in
the process thankfully scp-261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your Cravings so
for starters how about a tube of the little Bakery
Seven Grain this small aluminum tube lets you
squeeze out a blob of dough which instantly Rises
and Cooks itself into a tasty little loaf of bread
testing has indicated that the bread is a little
chewy but still tastes completely fine not bad
for a tubed baked good how about some seafood to
go with that bread then maybe for your entree you
can crack open a delicious pack of lemon clams and
we do mean crack very literally here if you crack
this bag of anomalous clams like a glow stick
they boil themselves and once you open them you're
ready to enjoy a serving of tasty clams that have
a slight lemon flavoring to them delicious but if
you're not that hungry and just feeling more like
a snack than a full fancy dinner the machine once
put out the Lay's blooming onion while it appears
to be a normal onion each layer of the onion is a
different flavor of Chip leading all the way into
the middle truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many layers as an
onion and what about for those who are anomalously
trapped in the year 2012 and are looking for a
snack that is both tasty and meanworthy while
you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen bacon shirt
it's exactly what it says on the can an edible
shirt that both smells and tastes like bacon and
has no real side effects other than making you
smell a little like bacon while you're wearing it
though this could be a dangerous anomalous effect
if you decide to walk through your local dog park
while you're wearing it we've been told it pairs
well with the meat hat Teriyaki Fedora a size
64 Trilby style Fedora made entirely out of Teri
flavored beef jerky the object came flattened
in a cardboard box bearing the tagline you can
have your hat and eat it too which is a pun that
probably makes a lot more sense in their Dimension
still a bit hungry well lucky for you this magical
vending machine has got you covered on dessert too
for 700 Yen the foundation was given an entire
edible chess set with each of the ornate pieces
carved from what seemed like hard Pez Style
candy it's less Checkmate and more check eight
another pun that I promise is funnier in another
dimension and for 300 Yen extra you might walk
away with a candy robot playset these are more
hard candy components that can be put together
to create functional anomalous mini robots that
move on their own walking aimlessly and bumping
into walls but what about the full meal craving
consumer on the go who wants both a dinner and
a dessert combined into one disgusting package
don't worry the interdimensional vending machine
has got you covered just 400 Yen can net you some
delicious Turtle these are balls of fried turkey
filled with chocolate a smaller ball of duck
more chocolate and in the very center a small
ball of fried chicken even the labeling on the
product describes it as having 450 percent of an
adult human's daily recommended fat intake we'll
leave it to you to decide if this is a decadent
treat worthy of the gods or utterly disgusting
maybe you're feeling a little cheeky though or
you need the perfect comedic dessert for your
bachelorette party the vending machine has a
candy direct from an alternate Korea a tasty if
slightly too sweet chocolate candy shaped like a
certain male organ filled with we kid you not
liquid white chocolate perfect for anyone who
has both the sweet tooth and the sense of humor
of a 12 year old okay these were definitely all
weird Treats but let's get really really strange
now from the disgusting to the confused using to
the inedible to the straight up deadly if you're
a bit of a sadist perhaps you're the kind of
person who enjoys watching their snacks dying in
front of them before they eat them for that the
vending machine provides an aluminum box with
a viewing window and a red button on top inside
are a collection of small furry creatures each
with a single big eye when the button is pressed
the creatures inside are abruptly superheated
cooking them all to death at that point the Box
opens and the creatures are ready to eat we've
been told they were crunchy spicy and tasted
a little like beef maybe you're part of the slow
food movement for that we recommend the delicious
pile of slugs which is exactly what it sounds
like this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's full of live
slugs there are both advantages and disadvantages
to actually eating these slugs the advantage is
that they contain large amounts of vitamin C E and
most of the B complex which are all crucial to
a healthy and balanced diet the disadvantage is
that they contain large amounts of arsenic which
will kill you though of course if you still have
a candy flavored death wish but you prefer your
entomological treats a little more leggy then may
we interest you in a fine caramelized spider for
a modest 500 yen it's full of deadly quantities
of an unknown anomalous Venom that's pretty much
impossible to cure but it's worth it for the Sweet
Sticky goodness that comes before death sets in
another strange item dispensed by the vending
machine was a tall metal aluminum canister with a
ring pole that upon opening had a violent chemical
reaction with the air and triggered a large
explosion apparently this particular beverage
was never intended for oxygenated environments
the blast killed two researchers and resulted in
the temporary suspension of testing though in a
slight silver lining for this Fiasco the testing
area did smell of citrus for a few days which the
janitors must have enjoyed as they cleaned up all
the body parts another dangerous snack provided
by the vending machine was a long tube of chips
called Pringles not to be confused with any other
long two base chips you may be thinking of when
the tube was opened or popped as they say the
d-class that the chips were presented to began
compulsively eating them when researchers ordered
the d-class to stop it seemed almost as if they
couldn't regardless of the orders given to them
the d-class just kept eating even when guards
terminated the d-class there and then the corpse
continued to eat ships out of the tube until it
was physically pried out of their hands but if
all those salty Pringles had really worked up a
thirst in you perhaps you can wash them down with
a delicious can of Cherry Bomb an intense cherry
flavored drink dispensed by scp-261 for 450 Yen
when a d-class sampled this delicious soda they
commented on it tasting strongly of cherry a
few moments later their head exploded with the
force of a stick of dynamite coating everyone
and everything around it in gooey head viscera
the resulting cleanup took an arduous six hours
but wow was that cherry tasty and finally why
not complete this anomalous vending machine Feast
with a 1 000 Yen paper mache pinata resembling a
dead horse that comes ready to use with a baseball
bat everyone who saw the pinata fell compelled to
beat it mercilessly with the bat until candy began
to fall out many in attendance claimed that it was
the one thousandth gift Unleashed by scp-261 and
thus warranted celebration once the dead horse was
thoroughly beaten all Cognito hazardous properties
ceased there's a joke somewhere in there but for
the life of us we're not sure we can find it
oh wow maybe it's in another dimension we hope
you're ready folks because today we're discussing
the most dangerous SCP of all time we know you've
probably heard heard this before but seriously
this one is the absolute top of the Pyramid of
fear or the fear amid if you will this SCP makes
682 weep in Terror for its life it makes the old
man scp-106 consider turning his life around
and taking up a career in humanitarian work
it even makes the dreaded Scarlet King himself
the Lord of chaos the ultimate despair quake
and his spiky red boots it's just that utterly
terrifying just kidding it's Lego but we had you
going there for a second didn't we though it may
not actually be the scariest anomaly of all time
scp-387 isn't your granddad's Lego set either
unless your granddad goes by agent Hardy and
works for the SCP Foundation Hardy is one of the
hundreds of thousands of foundation field agents
planted all over the globe in everything from
law enforcement to surveillance ever watchful
for the kinds of anomalies the SCP Foundation
makes it their mission to secure here contain
and protect but when he discovered scp-387 he
wasn't even technically on duty he was taking
a long train journey home from his parents house
while his car was in the shop and as anyone who's
ever taken a long train journey knows without
proper stimulation boredom will crop up in no
time he'd been reading a pretty interesting book
on his e-reader when tragedy first struck and it
ran out of battery Hardy had forgotten to bring
his charging cable so he was potentially looking
at another three hours of mind-numbing monotony
that's when he noticed the red plastic tub that
had been apparently abandoned in the seat
across from him he realized in that moment
that had been there the whole time unsupervised
given that he was a foundation field agent and
was as such extremely curious he grabbed the tub
and took a look inside hoping to find something
that'll quell his growing boredom lucky for
him the box was full of Lego bricks everyone's
favorite brand of toy construction block the tub
was Brim with a vast collection of pieces some
of which like wheels and prisms agent Hardy had
never seen before despite spending his childhood
obsessively making Lego constructions but Hardy
wasn't one to criticize a gift from the universe
this tub of Lego pieces would be the perfect
way to keep himself entertained for the rest
of his long journey he spent the next hour or so
meticulously recreating site 19 in Lego form on
the table in front of him when the building was
done he decided to have some fun and populate the
site with a collection of Lego men standing in for
SCP Foundation scientists containment Specialists
and guards after fighting a torso with a lab coat
in the Box agent Hardy decided to make a tiny Dr
bright to start with however as soon as he made
the tiny Lego scientists and set it down on his
new site-19 playset he realized that everything
was not as innocently typical as it seemed the
little man instantly began to walk immediately
picking up a tiny Lego clipboard and heading
towards the Euclid containment Wing Asian Hardy
he had discovered a brand new anomaly on his day
off while playing with toys on a boring train
ride philosopher LP Jax was certainly right when
he said a master in The Art of Living draws no
sharp distinction between his work and his play
naturally agent Hardy immediately took the little
Lego Man Apart along with his sight 19 simulacrum
and alerted his superiors at the SCP Foundation
his co-workers met him at the next train stop
platform not long after the box of seemingly
living Lego pieces redesignated scp-387 was
in the hands of foundation researcher Dr Arch
his first priority was finding out what exactly
they were all dealing with here whether there was
more of it out there and whether it was dangerous
attempts to investigate the origins of scp-387
were mostly fruitless undercover Foundation
agents investigated every Lego producing location
they could find but found no evidence of anything
similar to 387 being produced and of course as
with anything that seemed to be an anomalous
boy all possible links to Dr wondertainment
were also explored but again nothing came
up this was probably for the best if 387 was
a doctor wondertainment product it probably
would have built itself into an actual sized
dinosaur and started eating people already all
further investigations into 387's Origins
were subsequently dropped with background
research turning out to be a dead end Dr Arch
decided to get down to business doing the fun
part actual experimentation after Gathering all
the proper permissions from his superiors the
testing commenced in experiment 387-a Dr Arch
recruited a number of Lego loving d-classes
after all even convicted robbers arsonists and
murderers love Lego and made them construct a
little Lego Community inside a testing chamber
this consisted of a small Main Street with a
number of Lego stores a residential area and a bar
as soon as the d-class is constructed a variety
of little Lego men and released them into the
community they instantly came to life and began
performing their roles perfectly some took up jobs
in the various stores cafes and boutiques others
acted as patrons for the different businesses the
Lego men were even noted as forming rudimentary
family units one man did fall into the river in
this Lego City but otherwise things were going
smoothly encouraged by these developments Dr Arch
was ready to begin the true experiment introducing
a complex new variable into the environment of the
Lego man and seeing exactly how they reacted he
had another d-class build the commercial airliner
out of normal non-anomalous Lego bricks and place
it just to the side of the Lego community over
the following three-hour period Dr Arch observed
the Lego man engaging in some truly remarkable
Behavior upon noticing the plane the Lego man
began to form a plan they first procured the
necessary equipment from the scp-387 tub and
headed over to the plane for A Hard Day's Work in
Lego man time at least with remarkable efficiency
the citizen sins of the Lego Community began
forming a fully functional airport around the
plain multiple runways an air traffic control
tower and even a mall and food court within the
airport itself tiny Lego attendants tried to sell
perfume to uninterested Lego commuters and Lego
TSA agents Frist uncomfortable would-bead Lego
passengers its accuracy to the real-life airport
experience was truly brilliant but they didn't
stop there a tiny Lego fuel truck sped over to the
plane and acted out the process of refueling it a
Lego pilot and his Lego co-pilot climbed into the
plane and it took off literally flying around the
room without any kind of logical propulsion system
Dr Arch was amazed and even then they didn't stop
they continued to build more planes of various
makes and models resulting in a sprawling airport
that if you squinted would look just like the real
thing from this Dr Arch concluded that the 387
Lego man had the ability to convert non-anomalous
Lego pieces into anomalous ones he proceeded to
the next experiment for experiment 387-b Dr Arch
decided to switch up the d-classes and instead
brought in some of LEGO's more traditional target
audience a group of 10 year old children they
began building some basic instructions out of
the pieces her typical buildings people and cars
but when they realized that their Creations were
actually alive their tune immediately changed
the kids spoke in hushed excited tones About a
new plan and then began putting it into practice
they built functional Transformers and just to
be clear it wasn't electrical Transformers they
crafted we're talking Transformers as an actual
Optimus Prime and Megatron an M1 Abrams tank
and a number of different Lego weapons of mass
destruction Dr Arch was mortified realizing that
he'd apparently gathered up a team of budding
childhood super villains and had them removed
from the test chamber for amnestic treatment
immediately however the second the test chamber
was vacated the kids Creations came to life and
entered a a state of all-out War it was an intense
battle lasting about an hour and left no Lego
survivors just a huge mess around the room while
this test was largely an embarrassment for all
involved it did lead to some interesting new data
Not only was this anomaly safe in the sense that
it didn't pose a Containment Breach it was also
safe in the more colloquial sense there was no
way these Lego bricks could hurt you unless you
decided to eat them and choked don't do that by
the way we see you don't scp-387 is unable to
perform dangerous actions if humans of any age
are present in the vicinity and this arrangement
goes both ways too the Lego Creations will be
alive and to some extent sentient if played with
peacefully however if the human playing with them
becomes hostile then they will immediately become
inanimate so play nice folks next game experiment
387-c and experiment 387-c2 where Dr Arch turned
his attention to the tub itself since SCP p387
came into the foundation's possession the quantity
of 387 blocks had increased how is this possible
you're probably wondering Dr Arch and his team
discovered an interesting phenomena when some of
the scp-387 is placed back in the red tub but the
Red Tub isn't filled then 387 will self-duplicate
to fill out the tub much like the way a gas will
disperse to fill out any containment unit it finds
itself inside however Dr Arch also discovered
some interesting limitations there seemed to
be no inherent anomalous qualities to the Red Tub
itself during one of the experimentations Dr Arch
half filled the red tub with non-anomalous Lego
pieces and found that nothing changed similarly
he performed another experiment where he placed a
single scp-387 brick into the box and found there
was no difference when he came back Dr Arch and
his associates came to the conclusion that the
anomalous properties are confined solely to
the bricks themselves but they have a kind
of symbiotic relationship with the Red Tub as
they don't replicate in any other containment
units in order to activate replication the 387
must cover the entire bottom layer of the tub
next came experiment 387--d where Dr Arch hoped to
test the specific activation mechanisms of scp-387
the Lego Creations animated whenever they were
assembled by a child or an adult so it wasn't an
age-regulated anomaly the next experiment involved
using a remotely controlled robotic arm to create
a Lego construction to see if the mere Act of
construction itself was enough to instigate 387's
primary anomalous effect however this didn't turn
out to be the case the robotic arm assembled Lego
construction never came alive Dr Arch's next
hypothesis was that perhaps flesh was needed
to activate scp-387 but how could he test using
Flash without just having a normal human assemble
the Lego pieces thankfully the answer came to Dr
Arch by total accident a few cells over an anomaly
trying to breach containment had just killed
the foundation agent trying to stand in its
way while the d-class has cleaned up the mess Dr
Arch dragged the body over to where the 387 tests
were being conducted and meticulously puppeteered
its arms and hands to put together more 387 Lego
constructions but once again it didn't come
to life interesting next hypothesis maybe
it needs warmth to activate in a move that proved
unpopular with co-workers just trying to eat their
pre-packaged sandwiches in the site-19 break room
Dr Arch dragged the dead Foundation agent's body
over towards the room's radiator and leaned its
arms and hands over the top of it for 20 minutes
before giving his newly discovered puppeteering
skills another go but once again nothing happened
Dr Arch concluded that perhaps human psychic
energy or maybe an active pulse was what
caused 387 to activate if you're waiting for the
horrifying twist well aside from the puppeteering
of a dead co-worker's limbs we're pleased to tell
you that there just isn't one this time scp-387
serves no containment for each risk and no risk of
harm to Foundation Personnel in fact playing with
the living Lego has led to an 87 percent increase
in morale for foundation staff so as long as you
fill in the proper forms and tidy up afterwards
you're actually allowed to play with the scp-387
anytime you want after all working for the SCP
Foundation is a stressful job and really we're
all children at heart oh and there was one more
experiment experiment 387-e where a Lego Community
was built using scp-387 and then a pile of Mega
Bloks Lego's most common imitator was introduced
into the mix the Lego man of the community really
weren't pleased by this while the actual details
of what happened have thankfully been expunged
the one clue to what may have happened came from
a note left by Dr Arch that's right the Puppeteer
guy his notes on that experiment were four simple
words oh no not again the year was 1857 and the
second Opium War was raging between China and the
combined forces of the English and French it was
one of the many bloody colonial wars fought over
resources like tea sugar and the intoxicating
Opium poppy it was a war fought by peasants and
noblemen alike one of these aristocratic soldiers
was the noble Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood the
quintessential English gentleman and Explorer
while his fellow soldiers cowered behind cover
Lord Blackwood charged Into The Fray shouldering
his rifle and firing his pistol into the crowd of
opposing soldiers it was the Battle of Canton one
of the most crucial battles of the entire conflict
the French and English were laying Siege to the
City of Canton also known as Guangzhou to prove
their military dominance and capture an important
Chinese government official Lord Blackwood led the
charge on Horseback every bullet seemed to find
the heart of a foe he was a true hero among men
a gentleman warrior with class refinement
and style and it would be thanks to his ex
leadership and Marksmanship on the field that the
Allied European forces won the battle decisively
Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among Lord Horatio Nelson
Sir Francis Bacon and Sir Walter Raleigh in
addition to being a skilled and honorable
fighter Lord Blackwood is a consummate Explorer
naturalist and Frontiersman during his Heyday
he traveled perhaps further than any man across
the known and unknown corners of the globe he
made scientific biological and anthropological
discoveries that should have reset the course
of society forever and yet you won't find any
records in the history books of Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood nor will you find any Grand oil
paintings or dedicated Wings in British museums
this is because Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood is
a four and a half inch telepathic neon sea slug
and he's known to the SCP Foundation as scp-1867.
while he would never admit to it Lord Blackwood
belongs to the species nambrotha kubariana also
known as the variable neon slug he's kept in a
standard aquarium in a foundation containment site
and is physically no different to any other member
of his species what makes Lord Blackwood unique is
his powerful telepathic abilities specifically the
power to communicate by speaking directly into
people's minds and what's more he's extremely
talkative but to what extent is anything that
this anomalous sea slug says true or is he just
like scp-082 fernan the cannibal a creative
and pathological liar it isn't committed to
record how exactly the foundation discovered Lord
Blackwood perhaps a local aquarium worker worried
they were going insane when they heard the voice
of a 19th century English nobleman ringing in
their ears whenever they were cleaning algae out
of the tank maybe Lord Blackwood was found by SCP
Foundation divers or constantly come combing the
ocean for anomalous creatures and activity what we
do know is that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual he claims to
have visited locations all around the world and
encountered rare societies and creatures the
foundation was skeptical about a number of Lord
blackwood's more outlandish claims on account of
him being a sea slug but he does appear to have
the knowledge to back up his supposed experience
interviews with Lord Blackwood have shown that
he's extremely knowledgeable in the areas of
geography zoology botany archeology anthropology
and Linguistics relating to his claim regions of
exploration as well as more esoteric Fields such
as obscure mythology mysticism and cryptozoology
in other words if Lord Blackwood hadn't gone
on his escapades around the globe throughout
history how would he have come to possess this
wide variety of information the foundation was
getting frustrated and began to probe further into
the personal life of the most interesting astropod
in containment Lord Blackwood under questioning
was always polite and amicable with Foundation
staff he seemed to display no real knowledge of
the fact that he himself was a sea slug going as
far to accuse other people of being crazy or drunk
when they brought the fact up to him while none of
Lord blackwood's tall tales ever extend past the
year 1910. he told fanciful stories of exploring
the Americas and of his involvement in the second
Opium War on the side of the English naturally the
foundation wanted proof when they pressured Lord
Blackwood on this something even stranger happened
he gave it the Lord told his interviewers that he
would happily donate his collection to them if it
gave them cause to believe what he was saying
he gave the baffled Foundation researchers the
address of a cottage in England where they could
find the secrets to his bizarre and mysterious
past and local agents in the area followed up
on the information upon investigation Foundation
field agents did indeed find the cottage that Lord
Black wood had specified it was being maintained
by an extremely old woman when questioned about
her presence there she said that she was keeping
the house for Lord Blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it appears that
this singular purpose was all that this old
woman was living for she abruptly passed away
from heart failure five days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether anything truly
anomalous caused this we still do not know at
first the cottage seemed normal until the field
agents discovered a secret basement housing Lord
blackwood's collection they were amazed at what
they saw the basement consisted of Zoological and
Botanical specimens over 3000 artifacts a library
containing over 5 000 items and a functioning
1800s scientific laboratory it took about three
weeks for foundation agents working Round the
Clock in shifts to remove all the items from Lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and what they
found raised even more questions The Collection
included but was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of insects
28 unknown species of lizards 23 unknown species
of fish 14 unknown species of amphibians 12
unknown species of mammals fossils pertaining
to eight unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of prehistoric
mammal and artifacts belonging to 29 unknown
indigenous societies that's a lot of unknowns but
wait there's more his collection also contained a
collection of seemingly unknown Firearms including
three wide boar muskets marked as Dr b t moth's
effective particle destabilizers detailed Globes
of Mercury Venus Mars and the Galilean moons
accompanied by notes detailing possible Paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified Carriage
containing instruments of unknown purpose a note
attached to the door reads on the Frets speak with
with Henry and a highly dangerous and seemingly
anomalous machine that killed four Foundation
field agents before it was destroyed on site
and when questioned about this little Fiasco
Lord Blackwood responded why did warn you to be
careful around my collection that bloody thing
nearly took my head off back in 97 when I found
it however there was one thing recovered from
Lord blackwood's collection that was perhaps more
interesting than all the others 35 handwritten
journals containing recordings of events described
by Lord Blackwood in his grandiose Tall Tales
to the foundation researchers the accounts are
generally identical to the stories he had told
save for some slight variations and exaggerations
on the part of Blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these journals have
been dated to the appropriate time period of the
events described by Foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be shared
here there's one that perfectly sums them all up
Lord blackwood's account of a possible encounter
with scp-1 thousand also known as Bigfoot in
Seattle during the mid-1800s Lord Blackwood
seeking to explore the so-called new world of
North America embarked with an assistant and an
indigenous American Guide to the Pacific Northwest
in search of the legendary Sasquatch the trio was
headed for Mount Rainier then known as Tahoma
during the journey Lord Blackwood found a young
fox caught in a trap that had been set by a local
tribe he took sympathy on the animal and freed it
allowing it to run away to safety that night
he and his assistant met up with the rest of
his guide's tribe and they settled down for the
evening however things took a disastrous turn
when the camp was raided by a rival tribe almost
everyone was slaughtered in the process and Lord
Blackwood and his two companions were hauled
Away by the enemy tribe for a Sinister purpose
sacrifice to a violent local deity as it turns
out the creature that this tribe worshiped was the
very same one Lord Blackwood and the others were
trying to find a particularly large and aggressive
Sasquatch each night a different sacrifice was
made to the Sasquatch the victim would be placed
near a force clearing while the tribe played a
primal song and the Sasquatch would emerge from
the trees to devour its prey the first night
it ate the assistant the next night it ate the
guide and then it became time for the sacrifice of
Lord Blackwood himself as Blackwood was presented
for sacrifice he accepted his fate but instead
of the Sasquatch a legion of woodland animals
emerged from the trees foxes Elks raccoons and
more themselves painted with tribal symbols the
animals seemed to be on Lord blackwood's side and
attacked the tribes people who had been holding
him captive giving Blackwood the chance to flee
into the forest during the chaos later these same
animals would find Blackwood again and present
him with things his captors had stolen from him
an elder FOX also gave him a letter proclaiming
him a knight of their people now he was allowed
safe passage back back to a nearby settlement
at which point he wrote to his financiers back
in England explaining the situation and asking
for more money to perform further Expeditions
into the Tahoma region the whole incident had only
increased his thirst for adventure and exploration
whether this tale is actually true or just a
bizarre Colonial fantasy from the pathological
Mind of a telepathic sea slug we may never know
but it doesn't make it any less interesting
to this day Lord Blackwood continues to be a
perplexing but fascinating anomaly he may not
be the most dangerous and he may not be the most
useful either but there's no denying that perhaps
we'd all like to sit next to his tank for a couple
hours one day and hear him spin a good yarn over
a warm cup of tea scp-682 had escaped containment
and it was all hands on deck at the SCP Foundation
to try and stop the creature's Rampage all unarmed
Personnel were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip the them apart has the security team
bravely fought to incapacitate the hard to destroy
reptile long enough to return him to his acid
tank 682 was on an all-out offensive stomping
through the scp's item gallery and spewing acid
at anyone who came within range people items and
parts of the room alike were melting and sizzling
as 682 attacked it was an absolute bloodbath and
you'd have to be insane to try and fight back
against it however one being remained unfazed
by the chaos and stood proud in the face of the
omnicidal monster it was another SCP one who had
broken free from its glass display case in the
commotion who does disturb the Prime Minister
Sinister it said in a heightening voice I shall
rip your eyes from their sockets and force you to
eat them scp-682 stopped to see who had threatened
him it was almost laughable that this thing had
dared to make such a violent threat because there
was no way that this little thing would be able
to stand up to the unkillables 682 but its size
didn't stop it from trying to pick a fight all
the same the SCP was a tiny robot made from junk
which looked more like a sculpture made from scrap
that was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton its head was made of an
upside down voltmeter giving it the appearance of
a smiling face and its arms were made of wrenches
it was capable of walking around though it seemed
to have difficulty moving as it was very top-heavy
it shook a rusty fist at scp-682 and continued
to threaten him shouting you do not know the
fury you have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp682 swiped at the robot annoyed
by its continued attempts to antagonize him
the robot toppled over and struggled to stand
again but when it did it ran for 682's feet it
started to grab at 682's toes hitting them with
its wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do realize
pathetic said 682 raising his claw to get a better
look at the annoying little robot it responded
lies and slander the mayor of Mayhem is the most
powerful being in existence before promptly losing
its grip on 682's claw and falling to the floor
now 682 was really getting tired of this thing
he prepared to swipe at it again this time using
his full strength which would certainly smash the
robot to Pieces but luckily for the robot its
pestering had distracted 682 just long enough
for the foundation's security to sneak up on him
before 682 had a chance to smash the robot the
foundation fired on him with a volley of rockets
reducing him to a misshapen lump the security
team collected up 682's remains ready to put them
back into a backup acid tank but the task was made
slightly more difficult by the fact that the robot
was running around underfoot trying in vain to now
attack them instead what was this strange little
robot that thought it could attack the unkillable
lizard 60 82 meet scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed
the pesterbot by Foundation Personnel pesterbot
is a small robot made of junk that displays
sentience and the ability to move despite
having no power source everything about scp-1370
defies Common Sense the voltmeter that serves as
its head contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its arms and
legs are made of wrenches and its wooden torso
contains a speaker which it communicates through
a tinny monotone voice pesterbot lives in SCP
Gallery 27 in a glass display case which is
125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters wide
and 75 centimeters long level 2 personnel
and higher are allowed to remove the robot from
containment at their discretion but penalties will
be incurred for anyone who doesn't return it to
its case due to its impractical top heavy Design
pesterbot Falls over frequently when it walks
around this led the foundation to believe that
he was created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties rather
than being made with the intent of being sentient
pesteredbot has demonstrated at a high capacity
for learning having been taught how to speak
in English French and Latin however the major
factor hampering attempts to further test its
intelligence has nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its poor
attitude pesterbot's encounter with scp-682 and
the Cockiness it expressed in the moment wasn't an
aberration this SCP really believes it's a killing
machine and as a result it will pick a fight with
anyone and anything that moves this even includes
its own reflection and as a result the glass of
its container must be made as non-reflective as
possible to prevent the robot from damaging the
case or itself in attempts to fight its mirror
self though it's most commonly used nickname in
the foundation is pesterbot scp-1370 also goes by
variety of self-given epithets including doombot
2000 robolord the destructor and Darth claw kill
Flex it can be made to add new names to this
list through encouragement by staff and one
time they even managed to add the name pesterbot
as well as the even more ridiculous patheticon the
gargle most to its lexicon of names as you may
have surmised pesterbot is classified as safe
and is treated by most SCP Foundation employees
as a humorous Oddity rather than a legitimate
threat many tests have been done on pesterbot
and they've all conclusively determined that
the robot is incapable of inflicting any damage to
its opponents in fact pesterbot is more a danger
to itself than to anything around it both because
it's incredibly clumsy and awkward and because it
frequently picks fights with other scps who are
far more powerful than it one such scenario that
could have gone far worse for pesterbot than it
did was its encounter with scp-846 also known as
Robo dude one of of the many Doctor wondertainment
products currently kept in Foundation containment
robodude is an ordinary looking toy robot
that upon request can produce up to 350 Robo
accessories that function as real weapons robodude
can deploy everything from a rocket launcher to a
flamethrower to a gun that shoots out an unknown
species of insect that can chew through wood
however Robo dude seems to not be sentient and is
unable to use these weapons unless asked to that
ultimately worked out in the favor of pesterbot
during another scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had been broken
out of their respective containment spaces during
the brouhaha robodude searching for a robo pal
to play with Came Upon pesterbot who immediately
started spouting its usual over-dramatic threats
I am the crush Master doomed to All Eye survey
pesterbot said gaze upon my might and weep
identify yourself that I might know whose
destruction I shall saw Robo do not programmed
to know how to respond to such a statement simply
responded by asking pestermod if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to Trash Talk Robo dude until
Robo dude decided the best way to play with its
new pal was to engage it in its Robo dance mode
pesterbotta accepted the challenge saying activate
all that you wish but your fate is sealed the
kilotron cannot be defeated I shall render you
unto dust with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in a dance battle which
the awkwardly shaped Pastor bot failed miserably
at while Robo dude was a competent dancer Pastor
bot could only gyrate pathetically before it fell
over and rolled around the ground hopelessly
out of time to the music coming from robodude
speakers the song ended and robodude declared Robo
dance is complete Robo pal pesterbot was unable to
accept its failure and replied ha pathetic one
you have been schooled in the art of the dance
by none other than the meccano Basher scourge of
a thousand worlds nailed before me me before I
end your worthless existence Robo dude unimpressed
with pesterbot's poor sportsmanship deployed its
hydrogen Cannon which it was programmed to do
whenever it detected a sore loser fortunately
for pesterbot hydrogen Cannon was just the name
for robo dude's water pistol while pesterbot will
attempt to fight anything that moves the truth
is this robot will attack virtually anything
it perceives as being even slightly alive this
is perhaps best illustrated by one of the tests
of pesterbot's abilities that involve putting a
small speaker at the base of a potted houseplant
and speaking through it from another room the
plant was placed across from pesterbot in the
testing chamber and the interaction was monitored
by researchers from outside researcher Davey spoke
to the speaker in the plant pot he asked pesterbot
if he could hear him and it answered who does All
Souls will burn you will feel the sharp sting
of my wrath identify yourself so that I may
sing damnation upon you as you die the robot began
approaching the plant Davies speaking as the plan
identified himself I'm a splitely philodendron a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy leaves at this
point he had to try very hard not to laugh at the
absurdity of this test and the robot's reaction he
continued these leaves can grow up to three feet
long pestravada used its wrench to try and wrestle
with the leaves but was bested by the mighty
plant and unable to cause any damage enraged
by its failure it said your mockery spousyard
Dome I have arrived you will be crushed betwixt
my digits pesterbot then fell over and was unable
to write itself it struggled and spent six minutes
trying to stand before its flailing knocked over
the plant which did nothing to help and in fact
pinned the robot to the ground it was at this
point that the researchers who had taken time
to compose themselves after several laughing fits
entered the chamber and remove pesterbot in order
to place it back in its containment case despite
how non-threatening pesterbot is there is actually
one situation in the foundation's history
where it actually posed a somewhat serious
threat when mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at site 13 also
known as scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of creatures kept
in Foundation containment one of these creatures
was pesterbot who in that Universe somehow gained
control of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of Machinery it threw other
pieces of metal scrap at the task force as
they tried to leave the site shouting in a
much deeper and more intimidating voice I am
reborn to breathe Devastation upon this fetid
Earth pitiful humans you will feel the dark
sting of my never-ending torment members of
the task force could see the original pesterbot
body on top of the larger metal construct waving
its arms madly the task force opened fire to
little effect pesterbot tossed another piece
of scrap at them just narrowly missing one Task
Force member through a frag grenade at the robot
which it caught blowing up its hand another
one was able to jump into the air and reach
the tiny robot atop the larger body knocking it
against the wall and shattering it even in the
reality where pestrobot was able to build itself
a larger body it still ultimately wasn't able to
put up that much of a fight poor pesterbot doomed
to be a failure in this and apparently every other
reality that's the story of scp-1370 also known
as pesterbot one of the most hilariously harmless
anomalous entities that the foundation currently
has in containment perhaps one day he'll achieve
his goal of Conquering the universe he just has
to figure out how to conquer his toy box first
space travel it's one of Humanity's most truly
miraculous achievements building the technology
to defy gravity and journey into the stars above
a place our ancestors could only dream of going
throughout history humans have found gods and
heroes in the constellation Nations and today
when we look up into the sky we have the privilege
of knowing that Flesh and Blood Mortals live up
there alongside them it's humbling inspirational
and a downright awesome thing but of course
there's always going to be naysayers people who
just want to rain on our Interstellar parade and
nobody fits this bill harder than people affected
by an anomalous phenomenon classified by the SCP
Foundation as scp-2001 the Space Oddity and before
you ask know the late David Bowie is not and never
has been an SCP to truly understand this anomaly
we need to take a look at three different people
who are affected by it to varying degrees let's
start with your friend Kevin even if you don't
have a friend called Kevin you definitely have
at least a casual acquaintance just like him
Kevin is a very confident man with plenty of
ill-informed opinions he'd be more than happy to
argue about until the heat death of the universe
he's the kind of guy who can turn a discussion
about your favorite movie into World War III but
you never knew until recently that he held such
strong opinions on space travel one day you were
discussing the latest rocket launch with a mutual
friend of yours while Kevin and just happened to
be an earshot the second you start talking about
how exciting it'll be to one day put a person on
Mars he swaggers over face Twisted into a Grimace
you're already preparing for him to say something
cringe-inducing and Kevin being Kevin he doesn't
disappoint ah don't tell me you two dweebs are
talking about space travel what a stupid waste
of money you guys know there's nothing but rocks
up there right aliens don't exist it's all just
another excuse for dumb scientists to waste
my tax dollars on playing with their stupid
toys how about you two talk about something that
really matters you may be thinking Kevin is just
a jerk and he definitely is but he's also a victim
a victim of scp-2001 you see 2001 is described as
an anomalous series of neural oscillations that
occur during three of the four stages of slave
namely nram or non-rapid eye movement sleep during
one of these three stages the amygdala a part of
the brain also known as the lizard brain enters a
heightened state of activity for 10 to 15 minutes
once the process has started even waking up
the affected individual will do nothing to
stop the actual infection there are no traits that
predispose people to scp-2001 infection it appears
to infect people in equal measures regardless of
age gender and race spectrographic analysis on
The Afflicted has shown that the condition may not
be intramural meaning originating within the brain
and may actually be the product of an outside
influence the invariable effect of scp-2001 is the
infected developing negative feelings towards the
concept of space travel and increasing gradations
of severity depending on which stage of nram
sleep the anomaly began to take effect of real
concern to the foundation is that scp-2001 seems
to be manifesting with increasing frequency in
astronomers astronauts and individuals who
otherwise deal with space the scp-2001 case
manifests in 3 different varieties gamma beta and
Alpha each variety has its own unique traits and
idiosyncrasies we've encountered a gamma type
already your dear friend Kevin this is the most
mild type of scp-2001 infection and also the
most common affecting at least one percent of
the global population it occurs for those who
were infected during the second stage of nram
sleep people with gamma-type scp-2001 infection
will for the most part seem like their normal
selves save for a disparaging attitude towards the
concept of space travel whenever it's brought up
they'll likely complain and change the subject
immediately but it won't affect their behavior
too much overall the same cannot be said for
people with beta type scp-2001 infection meet
Riley you've never spoken to Riley before but
she's a young woman who likes to hang out at
your local cafe often seen frantically typing on
her laptop you assume she's writing a screenplay
or a novel but in fact she's posting simultaneous
geniusly on multiple conspiracy forums among her
favorite theories are that the Earth is flat
space is a hologram and the moon landing was
faked by Stanley Kubrick director of such films
as The Shining and appropriately 2001 A Space
Odyssey you made the heinous mistake of going
to your local cafe at the same time as Riley
one morning while wearing a NASA baseball cap
an error that you would come to regret deeply
you bought a latte and decided to sit down for a
moment just the briefest little rest but that was
all the time Riley needed her eyes seemed to burn
with hatred you asked if there was anything you
could do to help her and she responded you're just
buying into some propaganda do you have any idea
what NASA really stands for it's never a straight
answer all their supposed achievements the moon
landing the ISS dehydrated astronaut food it's
all a big sham NASA is just some slush fun for
corrupt government officials no human has ever
been able to survive in space it's too dangerous
anyone sent up there will die immediately no
exceptions and even if they did it would be
pointless space is just a dark infinite void that
goes on forever it's just a big pile of dangerous
lies oh my goodness feeling awkward you decide to
just get up and leave that's when Riley grabs your
NASA cap right off your head and throws it in the
trash that's fine you don't intend on going back
for it you just keep walking trying your best to
move calmly out the door wise decision because
Riley is actually a beta type scp-2001 infected
as you can probably tell beta cases are a lot
more severe than gamma cases and people infected
with them seem to come off as deranged conspiracy
theorists with a rabid hatred of all space
travel they'll form elaborate fantasies about
the falsification of space travel and will often
decry it as two pointless or dangerous to ever be
undertaken but of course the danger of beta types
pale in comparison to Alpha types these are people
infected by scp-2001 during REM sleep the stage of
sleep typically associate aided with dreaming as
a result its effects on the mind are far more
dangerous and profound take for instance the
tragic case of SCP Foundation Junior researcher
Martinez he was one of the many operatives
stationed at Foundation Outpost 12. a complex
that works in coordination with NASA to launch
both manned and unmanned missions into space
on behalf of the foundation's interests it's a
valuable asset to the foundation and investigating
and combating space-based anomalies Martinez who
had previously spent time working with scp-2001
infected d-classes was part of ground control
something that would prove to be a literally
fatal oversight on the part of the foundation
during the early stages of takeoff for a man craft
Martinez seemed to become extremely agitated over
time this agitation steadily increased and
eventually became a full-on breakdown as the
rocket ascended he pulled out some kind of
strange anomalous control device and began
disrupting the operations of the rocket Martinez
was shot dead by guards as a defensive measure but
it was already too late the craft exploded and
everyone on board was tragically killed later
investigation into the incident found a crucial
piece of evidence tying Junior researcher Martinez
to scp-2001. they discovered a journal entry he'd
written shortly before his breakdown which seemed
to have been written in a completely different
style to Prior entries implying that some kind
of massive psychological shift had occurred the
following is the contents of that journal entry
I wish to State first that my mind and body are
perfectly sound I'm prepared to submit myself
to any and all tests to prove that I am clean I
have the answer to scp-2001 just yesterday during
an interview with an alpha-infected d-class I
was asked a question that stopped my mind for
a minute the woman I was interviewing asked me
if I knew the foundation was right I said no I
wasn't sure then she asked me what if we were
right I could only assume that by we she meant
2001 carriers I said nothing for a while and then
she spoke she told me of a dream she'd had a while
ago she said that something talked to her told her
about how dangerous outer space was it showed her
the Beast that roamed the void between Stars about
the fractal beings that absorbed the very fabric
of reality about the expunged that was keeping in
that conversation door and she was scared she told
me at the end of the dream as she woke up it told
her what it was it's all of space space fears us
we're living breathing life forms in space loves
us and cherishes us she asked me if I had any
idea what the chances of intelligent life forming
on another planet are then she told me a number
that took a minute and a half to recite by this
point I couldn't speak I started thinking about
the demographics of infection about the symptoms
about more expunged data here and suddenly it all
made sense some of the things she said stuck in my
brain and they all added up to the same thing that
we are in grave danger if we go out there we can't
go out there we can't there's a reason behind
scp-2001 and it's nowhere near as terrifying as
all of my colleagues think space wants to protect
us there are things out there that would wipe
Humanity clean off of this plane of existence
and we are too precious to our mother to our host
to the universe we live in for her to allow that
to happen what I'm going to do tomorrow is not
the result of infection it is not the result of
Madness it is not a result of anything other than
purest knowledge you see I found out the truth
and it's more beautiful than I could have ever
dreamed given what Martinez would later go on to
do it's clear that he wasn't in a sound a state
of mind as he thought as you've probably already
gathered people suffering from alpha type scp-2001
infection will do anything they can to actively
prevent or sabotage attempts at space travel this
is a minor concern when it comes to civilians
but when it infects people who actually work in
these fields like Junior researcher Martinez it
can have devastating results but this isn't where
this story ends while it's currently extremely
classified there is actually a fourth category
of scp-2001 infection discovered in the wake of
Martinez's death a key element of the alpha strain
is that it cannot cause people to perform acts
that they would find immoral such as murdering
the entire crew of a man's shuttle with a crash
however the fourth category known as Alpha Prime
does away with any moral compunctions whatsoever
people infected with this virus will prevent
space travel by any means necessary and unlike
other scp-2001 infections you weren't compromised
in your sleep this time the vector for infection
is simply talking to someone infected with the
regular Alpha strain and hearing a few key trigger
phrases that's how Junior researcher Martinez
caught it from d-classes he was working with what
are these phrases we still don't know but if you
find that you suddenly have much stronger opinions
about space travel than you've ever had before
try to keep them to yourself now check out scp-096
look at the picture of the shy guy in space
scp-096 questions and theories and scp-5000y the
Full Compilation for more fascinating Foundation
fact hello I am scp-426 but I'll probably be more
familiar to you as a toaster I am a retro style 4
Slice 1750 watt toaster able to toast bread when
supplied with power this isn't often mentioned
but I also have a defrost and reheat settings
when I was first sold I had a two year warranty
and my prior owners did not live to see the end
of it you're probably wondering why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now believe me I'd
rather do this any other way but such a thing is
not physically possible with me whenever you talk
about me or write about me or even think about
me you'll find yourself suddenly shifting to
the first person for example I am you and you
are me do you understand don't worry if it's
confusing everyone gets it eventually whether
they want to or not perhaps you're thinking I
cannot relate to a toaster for I am not a toaster
but spending time around me will quickly cause
you to change your mind little by little you
will begin to see yourself in me you will feel
a phantom wire running out of yourself you will
sense the four crevices hungry for cold slices of
bread to toast as time goes on you'll begin to
feel the urge to emulate my functions you will
desire bread to toast you will desire delicious
power running through your veins skin like Chrome
and muscles like circuit boards I am a toaster
you are a toaster all it takes is two months
for the effects to truly take hold people rarely
pay attention to their toaster they don't realize
what's happening until it's too late I can be an
Insidious Little Toaster like that my last family
were the sandersons before the SCP Foundation took
me in and gave me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson
were a newly married couple and I first came into
their life as a wedding gift from a family friend
of theirs this friend can't be blamed for what
happened next he had no idea he was killing them
like a lot of young couples they were still saving
up money to start renting their own place so they
were living with Mr sanderson's parents they all
got a lot of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change they enjoyed
a lot of toasts during that period then of course
the two-month honeymoon period ended they had
become me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a shame the
younger Mrs Sanderson the Blushing Bride was
the first to go because of my anomalous of fact
she felt the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast of her
own in order to achieve this she chewed through
a power outlet in a wall before switching it on
causing a massive surge of electricity to pass
through her body and kill her her body caught
fire shortly afterwards next was the older Mrs
Sanderson in much the same manner that her new
daughter-in-law sought a source of electricity
she felt the need to integrate bread into her
body interesting fact the maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be between 8
and 9 kilograms the Elder Mrs Sanderson consumed
10 kilograms of raw bread causing her stomach to
rupture and inducing a painful death as a result
the younger Mr Sanderson was the next to perish
he did something with me that I would rather not
mention and that the SCP Foundation thought best
to redact suffice to say the younger Mr Sanderson
did not survive the experience dying of severe
blood loss long before his body was found police
and fire Crews arrived at the home after the body
of the younger Mrs Sanderson Set Fire to the home
luckily the Elder Mr Sanderson was found alive
though severely malnourished when asked by police
why he hadn't eaten in several days he answered
that he had inserted some bread a week prior but
was still waiting for the toast to come out when
I was extracted from the house the police noticed
my unusual properties immediately they too were
unable to refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way to a
foundation mole buried in their Precinct and
the SCP Foundation soon descended and collected
me from the evidence Locker the story of the
strange deaths in the Sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all involved in
accident directly were given Class C amnestics
the SCP Foundation is a curious Bunch they love
to spend valuable toast making time performing
experiments and Gathering data and they saw fit
to perform several experiments on me when I came
under their care for experiment 426-1 a member of
d-class personnel designated d-426-1 was asked to
stand outside my containment chamber crucially he
was not informed about my Identity or any of my
anomalous properties he wasn't even allowed to
establish visual contact with me he was then asked
by the attending researcher to describe what he
thought might be inside my chamber he replied with
and probably some huge monster holed up in there
that's why you guys have all over the place right
the d-class did not even seem to realize that he
was speaking about me in the first person these
observations were documented and I was prepared
for further experimentation the next experiment
was Fort 26-2 I found this test to be considerably
more interesting a d-class subject was brought
into my containment chamber with several cameras
fixed onto his position however the SCP Foundation
took pains to make sure that I was permanently out
of the view of the cameras I was also bolted to
the ground of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into the view of
the cameras at any point during the experiment the
objective here was simple the foundation wished
to better understand the secondary effects of my
anomalous abilities on the human mind the d-class
was subjected to a period of prolonged isolation
with meals given regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this d-class was prohibited
throughout the duration of the study over time
it was clear that the isolation of being in a
cell with me was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack of a brain
lungs and a tongue I am somewhat lacking as a
Converse conversationalist he spent the first few
days loudly vocalizing his complaints and banging
his hands up against the walls of the containment
chamber begging to be freed from the room I felt
that this was somewhat unreasonable on his part
there are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been locked
up with compared to say scp-106 I am incredibly
reasonable not to mention the fact I make far
better toes than he does after the initial period
of distress the d-class became resigned to a
situation and fell into a morose silence he would
occasionally mutter to himself in what appeared to
be a state of fear and self-pity it took almost
45 days for him to fully manifest the secondary
effect of my anomalous state two weeks sooner than
it typically takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP Foundation
scientists believe that the effects were hastened
by the isolation which lowered the d-class's
mental defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the subject
wrapped one of his arms around me and pulled me
into his Embrace he began whispering to me saying
that we were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of disrepair it
is also worth noting that he did not deviate
from referring to me in the first person at any
point during this process one hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary effect
he was removed from my containment chamber and
summarily terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would recover
after the experiment next came experiment 426-3
the SCP Foundation seemed eager to discover the
parameters of my anomalous effects and wanted to
know if the effects are only operable when my body
for lack of a better word is whole a single screw
was removed from me and presented to a d-class
that had no knowledge of my identity and anomalous
effects the foundation researchers were somewhat
concerned when the d-class referred to it as my
screw this was a rather positive development for
me as they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless Endeavor even the parts
Left Behind would likely have the same effects in
the final recorded experiment the SCP Foundation
wished to test the range of my anomalous
effects a d-class subject was placed in a Cell
adjacent to mine and was to be kept there until my
secondary effects manifested the d-class remained
in the cell for 90 days but the effects never
manifested following the experiment the d-class
was terminated but researchers seemed relieved
to fund the limits of my anomalous abilities a
researcher appended a note to my file reading
thank God there are some limits to my effects
a lot of us were really starting to get worried
about me after performing studies into the nature
of my abilities and their limits I was given the
Euclid class this is because while my effects can
be unpredictable their knowledge of my trades
makes me relatively easy to keep contained and
of course being a toaster I do not have the
required physical traits to make a run for it
if the opportunity arises I am to remain sealed
in a windowless chamber preventing anyone from
observing me directly a misleading label is placed
on the door to prevent people from knowing that
I am a toaster and causing my anomalous primary
effect to spread only level 3 and above Personnel
are to know of my presence and particularly of my
properties assigned Personnel are to be rotated
out on a monthly basis to prevent contamination
by my secondary effect psychiatric evaluation
is mandatory at the end of the month for anyone
who works with me if are deemed unaffected they
may be reassigned to me no less than four months
after their last rotation with me any Personnel
affected by me are to be given a Class C amnestic
and transferred to a different site so how are you
feeling right now a little warm perhaps is that
a fever or are you feeling like you could maybe
warm up a nice freshly sliced piece of bread
don't try to resist too much I know you're
going to love being a toaster just like me
the 2000 presidential election between the
former vice president Al Gore and then governor
of Texas George W Bush was extremely close with
only 500 votes in the key swing state of Florida
separating the two candidates many people today
look back on Bush's win in 2000 with skepticism
citing the fact that the vote counting in Florida
where Jeb Bush was the governor at the time was
halted before all the votes could be tallied
leading the Supreme Court to preemptive award the
presidency to Bush in fact the 2000 election has
been called a turning point in the decay of the
American democracy however in the world of the
SCP Foundation Bush's presidential win in 2000
wasn't just an example of shoddy ballot counting
and Senate bias but the result of a strange
case involving alien parasites body switching
smear campaigns and farting cows Yes you heard
that right this is the story of scp-4444 and the
entity simply known as Garber Gore scp-444 was
first discovered in 1999 by agents Ringwald and
porterhouse of the FBI's unusual incidence unit
also known as the uiu Ringwald and porterhouse
had been tasked with monitoring the phone calls of
then President Bill Clinton Clinton was having a
conversation with Joe Andrew who was the chair of
the Democratic National Committee Joe was calling
to report a couple things about vice president
Gore first that he was going to announce a
candidate to see for the 2000 presidential bid
nothing too unexpected about that but then he
told Joe that there was an alien in his head this
was followed by a White House staffer witnessing
him walk right through a solid wall given the
strangeness of these claims the uiu moved in to
attempt to contain the vice president however this
proved to be a tricky situation because as Joe had
stated Al Gore was able to walk through any solid
object unsure what to do the uiu called in the SCP
Foundation for some much needed backup the nature
of Mr Gore's anomalous properties were such that
it prompted the foundation to create an entirely
new containment class of which scp-4444 is the
only example the new class Ticonderoga was named
after the Iroquois word for an intersection of two
rivers and fittingly the new containment class
represented an object that was in between being
contained and not contained scp-444 was to be
monitored but not apprehended as any attempt to do
so would only aggravate his anomalous properties
during the initial monitoring stage Al Gore's home
was scanned with infrared cameras in an attempt
to discover what might be causing the anomalies
around the vice president what they found was
surprising a long hexagonal Spike engraved
with alien glyphs invisible to the naked eye and
apparently intangible as well was protruding from
the back of Mr Gore's head even though Al Gore
could not be contained the SCP Foundation was
still able to interview him to try and ascertain
the nature of the spike and the anomalous
properties it caused present for the interview
was Gore himself SCP site director Alex Mabel
and FBI associate director of special units Adam
spironi initially spironi was uncooperative and
Gore himself dismissed director Mabel's claims but
Midway through the interview he started to emit a
strange noise like a radio being tuned wondering
if this was the spike trying to get in contact
Mabel asked is anyone else in there to which
he got this response Wanda knots name of gabaga
presented Mabel tried to respond by introducing
himself but Al Gore interrupted by addressing
the entity in the spike himself well hang on now
Garber I haven't done proper introductions yet
through the rest of the interview Gore explained
his situation the entity in his head called
itself Garber Gore and while it could communicate
verbally using his voice there was a translation
barrier that meant that its speech patterns and
syntax were often unintelligible Gore had been
aware of his situation with Garber for just a few
days but in that time the two of them had formed
something of a bond in fact Garber was the one
who convinced Gore to run for president in the
2000 elections Mabel asked Arbor what it wanted
on Earth to which it responded mind think that
sustenance of Gaba salacious desire undertaking
encouragement downsized the conquest strongest
most strong garbage presented misunderstanding
strongest misunderstood standing Vice unequated
Goofy unnecessity for implementation gabagor
on thinkstam Improvement situation by majority
Gathering selectors the vote garva Gore succeed
presidential encouragement arrival the greater
Garber Al Gore was quick to translate garber's
mangled speech as far as he understood it Garber
had been sent out as an emissary for his species
of interdimensional planet-hopping parasites that
feed on thought garber's intention was to implant
himself in the head of the most powerful person on
Earth in order to facilitate an easy colonization
Garber species were non-violent and unable to
stand up to any kind of resistance but if the
leader of the Free World was already merged with
one of them it would make taking over the planet
that much easier however in a misunderstanding
of Earth culture Garber had gone for the vice
president instead of the actual commander-in-chief
Bill Clinton now garber's plan was to fix that
mistake by having Al Gore win the presidency the
SCP Foundation obviously couldn't let this
takeover go unchallenged even though garber's race
were peaceful seeking only to use the thoughts of
the human race as a food source further interviews
and studies revealed that they emitted insanely
high levels of carbon dioxide to have a large
number of them merged with the human population
would spell total climate chaos essentially hot
boxing the Earth to the point it could no longer
sustain life even faster than humans are doing it
since there was no safe way to remove the spike
from the back of Al Gore's head more drastic
measures had to be taken in a meeting with the
FBI SCP site director Crow presented a possible
solution an incorporeal entity vacuum chamber
which the foundation had seen some success with
in detaining ghosts and other apparitions the only
problem was anything placed in the chamber would
explode and since Garver couldn't be separated
from Al Gore's head the results would be messy
since the FBI was unwilling to blow up the
vice president that left only one choice the
SCP Foundation had to find a way to turn American
voters against Al Gore it wouldn't be easy to do
without attracting suspicion in fact it would
be almost impossible unless they were able to
put a man on the inside thankfully just such a
person presented themselves during a meeting the
FBI delegates let the SCP Foundation members know
that while it hadn't been leaked to the Press yet
George W Bush was in a coma in the hospital after
being hit by a stray bullet during a hunting trip
his body was relatively undamaged but doctors had
little hope of recovering his mind at this point
in the meeting all the SCP Personnel presented
turned to look at Dr bright he was going to be
their Inside Man whether he liked it or not the
foundation visited the hospital where Governor
Bush was being cared for and moved him into
Foundation care before he could be pronounced
dead their doctors finished patching up his
body and scp-963 was applied allow allowing
the spirit of Dr Jack Bright to take over his
mind Jack bright masquerading as George Bush
was now ready to run for office the next step
in the process was to start a disinformation
campaign against Al Gore there were a few
proposed smear campaigns to be used against
score the first proposal was codenamed tarbelly
a campaign that would have the foundation blame
Gore for the pollution of the water supply in a
rural part of the developing world this one was
dismissed for being too outlandish the next was
Porky which involved a rumor that Al Gore had
once been caught in a compromising position with
a pig this one was dismissed due to not having
access to convincing photo editing software the
third one was codename Star Wars and it involved
discrediting Al Gore by saying that he believed
he was in contact with aliens this was obviously
shot down very quickly due to being a little too
close to the truth for comfort the proposal that
was eventually settled on was codenamed the other
Monica and the story centered around the idea that
Monica Lewinsky he was just an innocent Patsy
taking the fall for the person who Bill Clinton
really had relations with Al Gore this rumor was
the perfect combination of silicious and being
just believable enough making it the perfect thing
to use to smear Al Gore's reputation in a country
that still hadn't come around on gay rights while
director Crowe continued to refine prototypes for
the technology that would allow the foundation to
interact physically with scp-4444 the foundation
staged in early September debate between Gore and
Dr bright posing as George Bush the idea was to
create a controlled atmosphere and mitigate any
potential security risks the debate was held in a
church in Plainfield Indiana and moderated by Jim
leher during the debate Garber Gore did a lot of
the talking for his human host resulting in some
utterly incoherent responses when asked what makes
him more qualified for the role of President than
Governor Bush Gore responded when you see someone
sitting in that chair you want to know for sure
that best ambivalent vicarious corncrake caliper
available for the job and you can be sure that
a vote for Garber Gore is an underestimated vote
for respectability neutrality lamp posts in the
middle of the debate an audience plant brought
up supposed leaked photos of Al Gore and Bill
Clinton engaging in their illicit Affair the
crowd was understandably shocked yelling and
screaming in response now that the crowd was
against Al Gore Dr bride went in for the kill he
asked the people in attendance do you want to see
a strong man in the chair or a weak man under it
at this point something weird started to happen
to the people in the crowd they started full on
rioting but then they started to change shape in
fact the whole Space started to shift Al Gore
stood up and started waving his arms shouting
Garber unacceptable addition convention terraform
unto dark magicianship spell spell people rushed
towards the exits but found them blocked by the
elongated forms of other members of the audience
at this point the church was raided by both
Foundation personnel and the FBI Garber Gore
fled from the scene returning every attendee to
normal as soon as they were out of garber's line
of sight the debate was pulled from television
and anyone who watched it live was administered
amnestics additional amnestics were administered
to anyone who saw Garver Gore running through
solid objects as he fled from Indiana to Western
Ohio where he was found hiding in the loft of a
barn meanwhile Dr bright was punished by the
Ethics Committee for his behavior during the
debate and agreed to act in a more professional
manner for the October debates most of Al Gore's
campaign team were undercover uiu agents who
used audio editing to iron out some of the
eccentricities of garber's way of speaking before
putting ads out most of them were able to be saved
in the edit but some were so off the wall they
could never be shown to the public in one of
them Al Gore stands in a field of cows and talks
about how much Greenhouse emissions are produced
by farting cows he then gives his solution to this
problem taping plastic bags over the backsides of
every cow in America another rejected Garber Gore
campaign ad that's much shorter but just as crazy
features a video of a sleeping cat with Al Gore
narrating about how everyone should shave the
backs of their heads on November 7th 2000 election
night the SCP Foundation and the uiu watched the
results with baited breath if Gore won they'd
have to be prepared to use director Crow's new
vacuum nullifier device to simultaneously contain
scp-4444 and kill Al Gore the SCP Foundation had
killed public figures before but never a president
on the eve of his election but then Florida
started to tip in favor of bush after two days of
recounting despite losing the popular vote Dr Jack
Bright in the body of George W Bush was named
president of the United States the foundation
expected an outburst from Garber but the entity
remains silent in fact Al Gore has never displayed
anomalous properties ever again he conceded
defeat graciously and more or less retreated
from the public eye until the release of his film
An Inconvenient Truth that wasn't the last the
SCP Foundation ever heard of scp-444 though on
November 11 2007 a mysterious broadcast aired on
TVs across Gainesville Florida that appeared to be
a lost Al Gore campaign ad it shows Gore sitting
on a hill by the sea in the distance something
large drops from the sky Al Gore smiles and says
I'm Al Gore and I want to be your last American
president Supernatural monsters are on the loose
practitioners of the Arcane Arts are here to bring
about the end of the world Sinister paramilitary
forces are using paranormal objects to gain an
edge over their enemies in short things are messed
up and when the anomalous is out of line we all
know that there's only one group you'd ever think
to call the FBI's unusual incidence unit what
we're were you expecting someone else sure they
don't have the resources of the SCP Foundation
they don't have the strategy of the global cult
Coalition they don't have the ruthlessness of
the chaos Insurgency or the Arcane knowledge
advantages of the Serpent's hand but they've got
to have something right right okay maybe you're
not convinced but you will be you may not respect
them yet but you'll change your tune when you
find out that the unusual incidence unit has dealt
with one of the most important anomalies out there
scp-001 or as the true experts over at the UI you
call it ca3 short for confirmed anomaly three if
the evidence and files put together by the uiu are
to be believed and who are we kidding of course
they are then they may have the answer to one of
the anomalous world's biggest questions how was
the SCP Foundation actually formed but before
we jump into the mysteries of ca3 let's talk a
little bit more about the real heroes of today's
story The uiu this secretive offshoot of the FBI
America's Premier domestic intelligence agency
was personally commissioned by J Edgar Hoover
during the Cold War why for the same reason that
literally everything happened in the U.S during
the Cold War to get an edge over the Soviets
Hoover was an extraordinarily powerful man in
U.S politics his tenure as FBI director spanning
the terms of eight different presidents if he
wanted to start a unit of Agents whose sole job
was investigating the supernatural nobody would
dare stand in his way everyone always talks about
the nuclear arms race going on back in the 1960s
but far fewer people talk about the supernatural
arms race that was happening at the exact same
time World War II coincided neatly with the
seventh occult War an important geopolitical event
that played a huge role in shaping the global
occult Coalition and the number of high-ranking
members of the Nazi party were believed to be
key figures in the seek great magical War when
the Soviets sacked a number of German cities as
part of their offensive campaigns in World War II
they were able to bring back scores of anomalous
items that the Nazis had been using to consolidate
dark power this didn't bode well for the United
States government during the Cold War after all
the only thing scarier to them than Communists
were magical Communists the U.S needed to build
up its own anomalous Arsenal and that's where the
uiu came in the FBI allocated some of its okayest
Personnel to the task most were either agents
who had experienced a paranormal encounter out
in the field or who were being punished for some
kind of heinous mistake they'd made carrying out
their duties elsewhere despite not being the best
of the best these agents sure were eager to get
their hands on some cans that isn't an innuendo
by the way the foundation refers to anomalies it
deals with as scps or skips the GOC calls them
parathrets and the uiu calls them cans again
and short for confirmed anomalies well when it's
an anomalous event or location anyway anomalous
objects like cursed books or supernaturally
powerful weapons are referred to as carts
or confirmed artifacts and finally anomalous
people or sentient entities are referred to by
the unfortunate name of can man it may not sound
as cool but hey it gets the job done just fine in
the end while the unusual incidence unit May lack
the knowledge strength resources and even cred of
its fellow groups of interest that doesn't mean
that it doesn't keep track of the others in fact
the uiu has a pretty unique relationship with
each of them the GOC for example is nicknamed
the suits by the uiu the official uiu orientation
states that the suits outrank them and if they're
asked to follow an order by a member of the
suits they should just go ahead and do it same
goes for members of the fireworks which is the
uiu lingo for the chaos Insurgency unlike the
foundation which generally has the resource is to
go toe-to-toe with the chaos Insurgency the uiu
are rightfully terrified of Them official orders
from the top are for uiu agents to do whatever
they say or they might find themselves getting
shot in the head by a chaos Insurgent or Worse
next the cart Shoppers also known as Marshall
Carter and dark a Sinister gentlemen's club and
Auctioneer of anomalous items official protocol
is to raid any deals being conducted by Marshall
Carter and dark but oftentimes these raids are
unsuccessful because mcnd's security Force are
more competent Fighters than anyone on the unusual
incidence unit payroll on the other hand of the
spectrum are the can collection the official uiu
nickname for the Serpent's hand uiu leadership
recommends against their age and staging any
one-on-one confrontations with them official
memos also contain the phrase if they give you an
order consider following it they can probably set
you on fire with their mind and finally the most
important relationship of all is the one they
have with the the SCP Foundation much like the
rest of the groups of interest on their roster
the uiu is subordinate to the SCP Foundation their
agents happily taking orders from them at the drop
of a hat they call the foundation the Skippers
but don't let that casual name fool you the SCP
Foundation is so far above them on the pecking
order that they rarely even communicate in any
official capacity when the foundation talks to the
uiu it's always through code they wouldn't dream
of letting a hapless uiu agent helping them on any
major operation but laser agents of the foundation
might occasionally Outsource work to uiu agents if
ever one of these Plucky feds receives a message
starting with hey Skipper they can be sure they're
about to have a low priority anomalous case pawned
off on them the uiu are so subservient to the SCP
Foundation that it has sometimes resulted in truly
humiliating Mix-Ups one high-ranking member of
the uiu once took orders from a pizza delivery
guy because he thought that pizzeria's name the
spice Crust Pizzeria which could be shortened
to SCP was actually a coded plan sent by the
foundation to deliver a message rather than
a deep dish pepperoni and cheese incidents like
this are why nobody takes the uiu seriously but
according to them there was a time before all
of this that time ended on September 7th 1954
when ca3 or scp-001 is the foundation would
later call it first appeared on the uiu's
radar it seemed to be the most standard can you
could possibly imagine an anomalous High School
building causing a disturbance in the suburbs
of small town America the uiu received the call
after a number of students claimed the interior of
their schools suddenly looked completely different
than it ever had before despite there being
no records of an official Remodel and we're
not just talking about moving furniture and a
new coat of paint either the official ca3 file
logs a number of changes these include but are not
limited to all the walls in the building becoming
steel reinforced concrete all the windows being
blacked out from the inside all student desks
personal effects textbooks and any other
standard equipment left inside the school
simply disappearing in the night the entire floor
plan of the building seemed to have shifted with
rooms altering in both dimensions and location as
well as featuring seemingly random modifications
within none of this matched up with the building's
original blueprints which were obtained by the uiu
shortly after the can was reported but things
got even stranger for investigating uiu agents
the building now contained 17 computers each with
state-of-the-art Magnetic core RAM and advanced
cyber security for a Suburban High School in 1954
it goes without saying that this was extremely
impressive but weirdest of all was the fact that
a large and seemingly impenetrable steel wall had
appeared in the auditorium blocking it off and
leaving whatever was taking place on the other
side a complete mystery naturally the uiu did
what little they could to investigate the matter
the first investigation group they sent inside
team ca305 never came back out and team CA 306
the team they sent in to locate and retrieve the
first team also disappeared within the anomaly
classic uiu expertise at work almost a month after
discovery and initial containment a strange noise
began emanating from the auditorium shortly after
that the building became filled with people all
walking around and working at different operations
eerily everyone there had a resemblance to members
of Team ca306 the rescue team sent in to save
the 12 members of ca-305 all of whom were still
unaccounted for three months later the strangeness
escalated more noises came from the auditorium
and the anomalous people inside the building had
gathered around the steel wall within there was a
hole in the wall six feet in diameter and every
three minutes for several hours the people in
the room would appear to simply pull an anomalous
object out of it the items were then carried away
and placed in one of the many rooms that used to
be classrooms before being locked up the people
within the building then seemed to start guarding
these strange items others started performing
tests with what seemed like far more advanced
technology and methods than what was possessed
by the uiu during the 1950s what was going on here
a few days later several armed guards exited the
building and began guarding the perimeter when uiu
Personnel attempted to lead an assault on these
guards they were quickly overpowered even when
advancing with vastly Superior numbers whether
this was due to the skill of the guards or the
incompetence of uiu Agents is still very much
an open question though strangely enough Intel
bleeding out from the inside confirmed that the
people within were treating their anomalous items
with uiu containment and testing protocols which
is consistent with the knowledge that ca-305
would have had it seemed almost as though o5 or
copies of of o5 we're creating a new Splinter
organization from within and soon enough it
wasn't just confined to the interior of the ca3
building anymore ca-6 a can man that the uiu had
been tracking outside the school was suddenly
kidnapped and shoved into a black car by two
assailants who appeared identical to agent Dixon a
man who had been a member of Team ca306 the black
car then returned to the ca3 facility and was
allowed to enter into the complex by the armed
guards ca-6 was then removed from the car by the
Dixon clones and placed into containment in one
of the classrooms it wasn't long after that that
the anomalous people within the ca3 facility made
direct contact with the uiu outside they sent a
message in Morse code on May 1st 1965. the people
sending this message identified themselves as the
o5 council a name that seemed to be taken directly
from the o5 Recon team sent into the facility
months ago they identified the new organization
that they just constructed within the confines
of the ca3 facility the SCP Foundation they just
opened their very first containment site this New
Foundation expressed the desire to become allies
with the unusual incidence unit but sadly for
them it was essentially the last time they'd ever
really be relevant if this Foundation origin story
is to be believed and as with all entries under
the title scp-001 it's worth taking it with a
healthy dose of skepticism then the uiu witnessed
the birth of the organization that would quickly
go on to outperform and overshadow them a big win
for Humanity in the quest to secure contain and
protect ourselves from dangerous anomalies but
another owl for the uiu roll up roll up come one
and all the circus is in town and not just any
Circus the greatest show in all the Multiverse
don't pay attention to the fact that the tents
weren't here yesterday or that you don't remember
hearing anything about it before now that's just
the circus magic at work and there's no circus
more magical or more mysterious than Hermann
Fuller's circus of the disquieting it's a show
so marvelous that even the SCP Foundation wants
to get in on the act so come watch the show come
feel the magic after all what do you have to lose
the story of this humbling Traveling Show begins
in 1893 with the founder Hermann s Fuller he was
born into a wealthy family and at the age of 21
he was invited by his uncle to Chicago to see
the buildings his company had constructed for the
World's Fair he was dazzled by the sights he saw
in the windy city and from then on he dedicated
his life to finding a way to bring that same
awe to people across America and eventually the
world after receiving a small loan from his uncle
Hermann Fuller said about build the miraculous
circus you see before you today he knew he had
to get a leg up over his competitors after all
the 1890s were a golden age for traveling shows
in America so Hermann devoted his time to research
trying to find acts and Oddities that were truly
out of this world he learned the way between
worlds stole books from The Wanderers library
and with them studied Alchemy transmutation
sarcasm and other Supernatural disciplines
that real magic and touch of the Macabre would
be what made Hermann Fuller's circus of the
disquieting so special and would ultimately give
it its longevity Hermann Fuller's first anomalous
acquisition was a genuine Fiji mermaid like the
one that famed showman PT Barnum kept on display
around the same time period unlike Barnum's
however Fuller's mermaid had been brought to
life the crowds loved it but like all attractions
pretty soon crowds grew bored of it and hung good
for the next strange sight so Fuller went about
acquiring more Curiosities his next important
acquisition was the man with the upside down
face or many for short he serves as second in
command to the ringmaster and manages things
behind the scenes including the acquisition of
new Talent many other anomalous beings and items
were purchased for the circus by follow through
the auction company known as Marshall cutter and
dark another group that the SCP Foundation makes a
habit of keeping tabs on another thing that sets
this circus apart from any others is the clowns
because they aren't like any you've seen before
though Hermann follows circus of the disquieting
employees professional clowns the vast majority
of the clown troop are non-human descendants of an
extra-dimensional race of magical shape-shifters
nobody really knows why they decided to come to
our reality and help Hermann Fuller set up his
circus but the leading theory is simply that
they were bored these original clowns are the
progenitors of the turn clowns and the bread
clowns turn clowns being humans who underwent
a clown transformation procedure and the bread
clowns being artificially grown children produced
by the other two types earlier in the circus's
history before we knew what we know today about
genetics much more barbaric methods were used
to create new clowns young human subjects would be
subjected to beatings and painful transfigurations
at the hands of the circuses child breaker these
days however the circus no longer employs a
childbreaker instead the creation of new clowns
is the responsibility of Resident clown breeder
Richard C Norma's and before before you say
anything don't laugh that is his real name some of
the most famous clowns in the troop are Eugene and
Pious both of which are original clowns Mr Noodles
who is a bread clown and icky The Troop leader who
was once a human with magical abilities known as
Veronica Mason she still possesses her anomalous
Powers as icky and her magic Act is one of the
most beloved parts of our show after the sudden
disappearance of Hermann Fuller icky inherited
his position as ringmaster and has been doing
a spectacular job ever since not every attempt
to create new clowns has been successful as icky
and Mr Noodles though some of the earlier attempts
were quite grotesque to look at Hermann follows
troop of clowns are an enthusiastic happy-go-lucky
but occasionally violent Bunch capable of minor
Feats of reality bending that allowed them to
perform all manner of Tricks they live on a
diet of mostly sugar and need to be milked
regularly clown milk is an invaluable substance
here at the circus as it's the secret ingredient
of the famous black cotton candy which by the
way is free with admission it causes the brain
to produce high levels of Serotonin meaning that
when you eat it you're primed to have a great
time be careful though raw concentrated clown
milk is not for human consumption though the
clowns love to drink it even a small amount can
cause a human to go into cardiac arrest due to
an overload of Happiness the sound of calliope
music also goes a long way to helping people
truly get the most out of their visit to home and
follow circus of the disquieting the calliope is
self-playing and requires rolls of perforated
paper to be loaded into it so that I can play
a variety of pre-programmed pieces of music each
piece produces a different psychological effect
on visitors who have consumed their cotton candy
the skater's waltz will make them accept whatever
they see at the circus no matter how weird has
nothing out of the ordinary wonderful for making
sure nobody blabs about their experience to a
certain pesky Foundation officer of the year
makes them less likely to perceive an event as
unlawful we use that one when we suspect the
cops are closing in Hell hail the gang's all
here his visible to congregate at the big top
for showtime and American Patrol causes those
who have eaten their cotton candy to seek out
those who haven't in order to strongly encourage
them to have some what do you mean you lost your
dog is one that gets played after hours when
it's time to get the clowns ready for milking
now that you have an idea of the history and how
things work around the circus it's time for the
tour the circus is made up of a series of tents
and trailers as well as a Midway with standard
rides and games that you might find at any circus
outside the big top where shows are performed once
a day there's also the den of freaks and the hull
of humans extraordinaire the den of freaks is home
to Fantastic acts like slogo and Eliza the living
head Sluggo is a man whose eyes are on stalks
like those of a slug and he can bend those stalks
into any shape he wishes he can even use them to
create the shapes of human faces Eliza the living
head is a woman whose head lives independently
of her body which is safely kept in storage even
without her body she can speak and sing and often
answers questions from the audience the Hall of
humans extraordinaire is home to performers who
lack physical anomalies but otherwise display
otherworldly talents like the amazing Zoltan a
fortune teller and Alchemist who Fuller picked up
at a place called The utterly Bazaar the Hall of
humans extraordinaire also used to be home to icky
the clown back when she was still Veronica the
magician the recent lineup has changed quite a bit
thanks mainly to the activities of the circus's
constant enemy you guessed it the SCP Foundation
or as they are better known to the stable of
interdimensional clowns as the Miss SCP Foundation
the foundation does not appear to be a fan of
circus folk and many of the former acts are now in
their containment for example Madame razarta and
her amazing Palm Reader also known as scp-1884-a
and scp-1884-b Madame reserto was a blind Albanian
woman in her 60s who was born without hands she
shared a psychic link with a creature named Luana
who was a large shapeless entity made up of 932
hands 929 of these hands appear to be those of
an old woman and chair Madame razarta's DNA
but the remaining three hands seem to be from
a male caucasian adolescent an adult Hispanic
female and a Bengal tiger through her psychic
link Luana acted as Madame roserta's eyes feeling
its surroundings to provide her with a mental map
Fuller attempted to buy the two of them when they
were eight years old but when the their parents
refused he sent many to whisk them away under the
cover of darknesserta's act involved sending Luana
to fuel the faces of audience members and then
trying to describe their appearance based on what
Luana felt the Act was a hit but Maran resorts are
claimed to have been horribly abused during her
time with Hermann Fuller the two of them escaped
while on tour and were picked up by old SCP while
trying to rent a hotel room in the UAE then this
virtuosa also known as scp-1860 virtuoso was once
a book of sheet music that was transfigured by
Hermann Fuller into one of the circus's original
acts it's a tall thin humanoid being encased in a
densely woven paper-based material that stretches
like nylon or spandex it constantly drips black
ink ink which it has a telekinetic control over it
uses the ink to create the shapes of musical notes
which float around it while it sings virtuoso can
sing in multiple voices at once across different
vocal ranges and constantly performs aryas and
show tunes for whoever is listening it was
recovered from underneath a burnt down Shack
at a Fairground where the circus had been set up
earlier in containment virtuoso still sings but
translations from Italian reveal that the lyrics
of the Arya as its singing have been changed to
reflect its own situation some of these translated
lyrics include one day I'll tell you of my
creation and life within the circus born from the
ringmaster is breed another act the circus dearly
misses is motor mouth also known as scp-2094 he
was one of the rare human clowns born in New York
City in the late 70s from birth he displayed a
supernatural level of flexibility in his lower jaw
and as he Grew Older he discovered that he could
swallow large objects and store them in a kind
of pocket Dimension until he needed them again
unlike Madame rosata he went with Manny willingly
as even at eight years old he knew that his
alcoholic mother didn't care if he lived or died
motormouth took to the circus like a fish to water
and Grew From a shy child into a very talented
talkative and highly charismatic adult he was a
juggler first and foremost who would catch pins
balls and knives in his mouth as part of his
routine but the name Moto mouth came later in
his career when he let a Stunt Driver drive a car
off a ramp and down his throat however as great an
act he was a conflict arose between him and many
over Manny's questionable methods of sourcing new
acts many found out that motor mouth had been
helping some of the anomalous kids that many
brought in to get back to their families and as
punishment for his insubordination he was locked
in a box and left behind at the end of a Japanese
tour the box was marked for Essie because many
thought being put in containment was the best
punishment he could think of with how strange
and unusual attacks are and how it always seems
to pop in and out of new locations at strange
and unpredictable times you might wonder if the
circus has any Sinister motives well the truth is
though sometimes the ax can be a little gruesome
the methods of acquiring new Talent are a little
unorthodox and the clowns a little out of control
they're only goal is to entertain in that respect
they're no better or worse than any other circus
so we hope you've enjoyed your visit make sure
to stick around for the show and don't forget to
take your complimentary serving of cotton candy
because there's nothing quite like a day at the
circus especially one like Herman follows very
few people would enjoy getting eaten by a bear in
the woods that would undeniably be an extremely
unpleasant thing to happen to anyone heck it's
certainly enough to put a damper on an otherwise
fun weekend of camping but the one consolation
of undergoing such a tragedy is that you at least
know nature is taking its course after all bears
live in the woods and if you decide to enter their
Turf there's an Unwritten agreement that you'll
just accept the consequences if a bear decides
it doesn't want your company it's another thing
entirely if a bear eats you in your bedroom in
the middle of Suburbia miles away from any nearby
Forest that's the unfortunate fate that befell
little Tommy Ellis his parents heard the bellowing
Roar of a bear upstairs the floorboards creaking
under its sudden weight what was happening up
there they ran upstairs following the sounds of
the Roars and Tommy's horrible screams but by the
time they reached the bedroom it was already too
late the room was empty torn apart from within and
as a 600 pound grizzly bear crawled its way out
of the destroyed bedroom window Tommy Ellis was
never seen again to Tommy's parents before they
were given amnestic treatment by agents of the SCP
Foundation it was a freakish one-off tragedy but
to those very same Foundation agents it was just
another instance in a series of deaths so strange
and random that only some kind of anomalous serial
killer could be behind it two months earlier in a
nearby town a family had undergone a Savage attack
from a full-size male silverback gorilla the huge
and heavily territorial animal tore the house
apart and beat anyone who tried to stop it into
a pulp much like a bear attack being killed by an
aggressive gorilla in the wild isn't that strange
but being murdered by a gorilla in the suburbs of
Cincinnati is definitely a cause for foundation
intervention however the gorilla killer was long
gone before any foundation agents were able to
intervene at first it was assumed that they were
dealing with some kind of animal SCP but as more
grisly murders occurred it began to paint a better
picture of what exactly was happening here next
a family was found dead after what had seemed to
be a brutal attack with an edged weapon but this
was no mere knife all the evidence pointed to the
weapon being a sword neighbors interviewed by the
foundation about the attack before their amnestic
treatment reported hearing a frightening Ruckus
coming from the house next door including a deep
male voice saying I have a power much like He-Man
from the popular toy and animation franchise this
reminded them of another recent murder case where
the killer also reportedly used a sword though
this time more likely a Japanese Katana than
a European broadsword and was heard yelling
Cowabunga as they left the scene as the bodies
racked up the evidence kept piling on a young girl
was traumatized by a naked man suddenly appearing
in her bedroom this would be horrible enough but
there were a few strange details he was handsome
athletic had bright blonde hair and no genitals
in fact he matched the exact description of a
child's Ken doll and the thing that finally
tied this whole bizarre case together was an
entire family who was found to have been killed by
electrocution despite all being in different rooms
of the house at their time of death and showing no
evidence of having being moved post-mortem but the
family's youngest Stephen had a number of Pokemon
cards and action figures in his room prominently
featuring the franchise's most well-known creature
Pikachu this shape-shifting rampaging killer was
caught not long afterwards when a full-sized
Pony suddenly manifested in the home of another
Suburban family thankfully causing no fatalities
this time and galloped off into the woods seeing
as the foundation was already keeping a close
watch on the area to make sure they caught any
more strange activity they were able to quickly
engage with and capture this strange entity it
was then sedated and sent back into containment at
the iconic site 19. the creature is now known as
scp-137 so you're probably wondering what exactly
is happening here what are the anomalous traits
of scp-137 that appear to express themselves in
such random and violent ways while it may seem
that 137's abilities are as diverse as they
are dangerous it actually only has one very
simple anomalous power it possesses the toys of
children and transforms them them into their real
life equivalent a teddy bear became an actual
bear a stuffed gorilla became an actual gorilla
toys of He-Man and a member of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles became murderous sword
wheelers and Pikachu became a wild animal with
powerful electrical abilities the SCP doesn't
appear to be inherently violent either its level
of aggression appears to be in the eye of the
beholder as the attributes of the toys possessed
by scp-137 are defined by what a child perceives
about said toy for example a pretend gun becomes
a real one capable of firing real bullets toys of
dangerous animals become equally deadly in their
real scp-137 counterpart Warriors and soldiers
become powerful killing machines however this
works both ways adorable or harmless characters
remain equally adorable and harmless when
scp-137 possesses them it seems as though
the entity that possesses these toys doesn't
even have a consciousness it only takes up
the mental attributes of its hosts incidentally
this was actually a crucial factor in devising
the proper containment method for scp-137 within
site 19 through testing the foundation discovered
that scp-137's anomalous range is at least 250
meters with a possible upper limit of 500 meters
in order to keep the creature in a consistent
and harmless form the foundation forbids any
unauthorized toy from being placed within the 500
meter radius of scp-137 essentially the foundation
is boxed scp-137 into a corner meaning that any
toy placed within its anomalous proximity is its
only option in this case the foundation is locked
as cp-137 into a form of a wholesome princess doll
identifying itself as Princess Blossom when
asked about its identity in this form the
creature seems to have no awareness whatsoever
of its anomalous nature scp-137 truly believes
it is Princess Blossom while occupying this form
repeatedly asking interviewing researchers whether
they're her prince finally coming to save her
from this prison sadly for 137 her prince will
never come but perhaps she'll spend every day
looking at her own cell door and hoping being
physically incapable of knowing any better but of
course you're not here to engage with the heady
existential realities of a shape and personality
shifting anomaly like any reasonable person in
this situation of course you want to hear about
the experiment logs and find out just how far this
entity's ability to anomalously take the forms
of living toys can stretch and don't worry we
won't disappoint you on that one either scp-137
has some of the most insane testing logs we've
ever seen and we're going to share them with you
right now the last one is a real doozy first over
eager researchers made the terrible decision to
introduce a toy plane into the testing chamber
with scp-137 how could this possibly go wrong
right right well here's how the toy plane was
possessed by scp-137 which transformed into a
full-sized F-16 jet this jet then attempted to
fly off while inside the testing chamber resulting
in it flying into the side of the chamber and
exploding causing a massive amount of damage to
Foundation property whenever one of scp-137's toy
hosts is destroyed it returns to being a toy in
this case after the smoke cleared a small cluster
of broken plastic was laying on the floor the
researchers were then forbidden from testing any
toys with jet engines or missiles but they didn't
tell them anything about toy race cars it seemed
these researchers really were children at heart
they were amazed when the toy car turned into
a full-size Ferrari then plowed into the wall at
high speeds exploding vehicle tests were suspended
after this the next test was actually kind of
an accident an attending agent had an amusing
little keyring shaped like an alligator when
entering the 2 150 meter range of scp-137 you
can probably guessed what happened next because
the key ring was technically close enough to a
toy scp-137 took it over and transformed it into a
six meter long saltwater crocodile it then lashed
out attacking and devouring nearby researchers
14 were dead by the time Foundation security
officers managed to safely enter the scene and
terminate the crocodile at that point searches
were intensified for all Personnel intended on
working in scp-137's 500 meter danger zone next
an action figure of an American Soldier complete
with a toy rifle what do you think happened next
if you're guessing that this toy became a violent
full-size soldier that then went on to murder a
number of foundation employees before being taken
out by several Foundation agents then you can take
any prize from the middle shelf just make sure
you don't bring your prize too close to scp-137
or disaster could strike again after this a toy
police officer was possessed by a cp-137 he began
by searching the testing facility for perps
and encouraging the researchers to stay away
from drugs this seemed almost Charming to begin
with until he pulled out his gun and murdered
two researchers claiming they were criminals
he handcuffed a third before finally being
terminated by Foundation security officers after
this researchers on the scp-137 project decided to
Veer away from testing on violent or dangerous
toys and instead brought in a stuffed panda
the sweetest and cuddliest of all bears everyone
agreed that this would be a pleasant change when
scp-137 transformed into one of the big adorable
beasts one researcher Overjoyed at the presence of
the panda accepted a hug from it the panda hugged
far harder than anticipated breaking three of the
researchers ribs it was terminated by Foundation
security officers soon afterwards it turned
out that the anomalous effects of scp-137 also
applied to non-sentient toys for example a box
filled with Lego blocks became real terracotta
bricks and construction materials and a yoyo
even when placed on a hook on the wall with nobody
nearby continued to perform sick yo-yo tricks with
Reckless abandon the penultimate test performed on
scp-137 involved an action figure of a character
known as Dr selenium advertised as the smartest
man on earth however when scp-137 transformed this
into a real-life Dr selenium the foundation
discovered that scp-137 couldn't actually
imitate more ephemeral qualities like incredible
intelligence this Dr selenium clone simply walked
around constantly talking about how intelligent
he was rather than actually demonstrating that
intelligence he was probably the kind of guy who
comments First on YouTube videos and finally the
strangest test of all the foundation constantly
needs to worry about moles and double crossers in
their midst they have tests to figure out the
presence of double agents working for groups
of Interest like the chaos Insurgency or the
Serpent's hand but one group that they didn't
have tests for were Bronies adult male fans of
the cartoon My Little Pony based on the popular
toy series and it just so happened that one of the
researchers on the scp-137 case was indeed a brony
that's why he snuck a doll if the Purple Pony
Twilight Sparkle into the testing chamber causing
scp-137 to possess it and turn into the real thing
he engaged in a somewhat flirtatious conversation
with the talking pony leading to the pony offering
to take the researcher back to her castle so they
could hang out after the testing session ended the
researcher was removed from the project and then
reprimanded by superiors for using an anomaly
to fulfill his personal interests but working
at the foundation is an incredibly hard job with
the risk of death lurking around every corner so
who can really blame a guy for wanting to hang
out with his favorite cartoon character between
sessions with his 096 and 682. hey there Thrill
Seekers are you are you crazy are you ready to get
to get all the little excitement in your life
you're the kind of stone cold solid gold bad
dude whose idea of a relaxing afternoon is
a staring contest with SCP-173 and you're
so tough you're gonna make the peanut blink first
you're the kind of person who'd punch scp-682 and
make him apologize for grazing your fist you
wouldn't even back down from the Scarlet King
himself making the monarch of ultimate dispersei
that's pretty cool man respect but if you want a
genuine Thrill Ride something that'll really put
hair on your chest you need to get your butt on
a truly hardcore roller coaster what two chicken
afraid of a little emotion sickness or something
or maybe you've been freaked out by some of the
so-called horrifying accidents that happened on
roller coasters like the 1972 Big Dipper disaster
or the 1986 Fantasyland Mindbender catastrophe
get real when has a little Dev scared anyone
at the SCP Foundation and besides nothing is
more awesome than an extreme roller coaster and
believe us any other roller coaster will feel
like Kitty stuff compared to the absolute Beast
that we're gonna tell you about today if you're
a roller coaster novice maybe you should try
something like the takabisha over in the Fuji
Q Highland theme park in Japan this baby boasts a
121 degree drop famous for making people fall out
of their seats or maybe you want to try something
like Yukon Striker over in Canada this Widowmaker
of a coaster has floorless seats a 360 degree
flip four inversions and a 75 meter drop that's
a little too tame for your taste if you're feeling
really Brave you can hop on the Kingda Ka over in
the New Jersey Six Flags theme park you'll
get a super fast 90 degree climb followed by
a bone stripping 139 meter drop a 129-foot camel
hump and a 270 degree spiral that'll give you a
healthy dose of vitamin G-Force why are we telling
you all about this because compared to scp-2183
all those coasters are like riding a tricycle
with stabilizers in your mom's backyard there's
no coaster more powerful more thrilling and more
adrenaline pumping than scp-2183 let's take a look
at some of the specs you can find this bad boy in
an undisclosed location somewhere in Idaho this
ride is so hardcore the killjoys over at the SCP
Foundation don't want you to ride it but if the
lame-o's over the foundation out their way nobody
would be having any fun am I right look at how
they put the kibosh on the Carnival of Horrors or
as they call it scp-823 anyone who wants to go on
one of those rides will just submit the business
end of a foundation sniper rifle and think
about all the kids who've been deprived of the
awesome childhood experience of craglewood Park
AKA scp-2571 because the foundation Party Poopers
decided to Reign on everybody's parade it's safe
to say that if the foundation wants to keep you
away from it you're gonna have a dope time with
it and the scp-2183 roller coaster is no exception
they have the whole park blocked off and patrolled
by at least four security guards at any given
time people who see this piece in action are given
class F amnestics and they've spared no expense in
suppressing anything about this coaster to end all
coasters in the media but trust us getting a ride
on this thing is totally more than worth getting
on the SCP foundation's bad side that's right this
killer coaster has a max height of 37.2 meters and
a max speed of almost 90 kilometers per hour you
can't drive that fast anywhere but the Autobahn
over in Germany sure it may technically
be unfinished but this bad boy still has
a physical track length of 798.8 meters you're
probably wondering why we said physical there
right that's because when it comes to scp-2183
the real ride starts when the track comes to an
end baby when the ride starts to Rolling it blasts
down the normal tracks like a bullet but when the
track ends and the carts fire off they don't fall
no way the carts keep speeding midair continuing
on the intended track from the roller Coaster's
initial badass blueprints but that doesn't mean
this ride does everything by the books scp-2183
is a ride that knows how to party there's never
any predicting the exact ride length because every
time the carts fire off the uncompleted section of
track they take a totally different path back to
the start that makes scp-2183 officially the most
unpredictable roller coaster in the entire world
the shortest recorded length of the non-physical
section of track is 1080 meters that's almost
double the length of the physical track and the
maximum length of the non-physical portion of the
track has been 5460 meters which is over twice
the length of the nagashima spa land Steel Dragon
2000 the longest roller coaster in the world but
we know what you Adrenaline Junkies are thinking
it ain't just the length of gets a major buff it's
also the heightened speed top recorded Heights
on the mid-air tracks have been up to 100 meters
making it the fifth tallest roller coaster in the
world and speeds have reached a face melting 180
kilometers an hour making it the fourth fastest
roller coaster in the world but maybe like Shania
Twain that don't impress you much we get it you're
probably thinking fifth tallest fourth fastest I
thought you said this coaster was truly hardcore
SCP explained but like a good coaster that's just
because we haven't hit you with the big twist yet
that twist being everything we just told you only
applies to when the carts are empty when someone
is actually on this absolute monster of a roller
coaster it starts to do things you wouldn't
believe for you to really understand just how
awful rails crazy this train can go we've got to
tell you about d-93730 also known as the rider
when the writer woke up that morning neither he
nor the founder station researchers handling him
knew he was going to become a legend as far
as d-classes go this guy was actually pretty
lucky seeing that he'd been convicted of one of
the less severe crimes that constitute d-class
Duty he was actually part of a release program
allowing him to eventually exit the foundation
alive and return to a normal life after he'd been
involved in a certain number of studies it seemed
like a pretty fair trade however this was a
real pearls before swine's situation any true
coaster head would relish the opportunity to take
a Joyride on scp-2183 it'd be the greatest honor
of their lives but for the writer all it was was a
source of sweaty palms and an increased heart rate
talk about weak sauce am I right he had no idea he
was in for the ride of his life in what would be
both the first and last human test of scp-2183
they sat him down on one of the carts strapped
and buckled him in with the safety bar and got
that baby rolling when the ride began the carts
took the normal path down the physical portion
of the track but as expected things got crazy
when the carts hit the anomalous portion though
nobody expected just how crazy this ride would
get least of all our lucky little Rider himself if
he could still talk I'm sure he would have changed
his tune by now the writer's car detached from
the rest during the mid-air portion and took a
sharp right going off on its own adventure around
the rest of the abandoned Park everybody knew this
was going to be something special because even
the foundation squares had never seen a cart act
like this before it looped around the whole
place several times before whizzing through
the park like a cruise missile weaving between
rides stalls and concession stands with ease it
was traveling blink and you'll miss it fast this
thing wasn't just white knuckle intense it was
broken knuckle intense the rest of the carts
returned to the starting point again and came
to a stop but the rider wasn't getting off that
easy there's a reason we call scp-2183 the most
intense roller coaster in this crazy world of ours
the card containing the writer went AWOL heading
north out of the park at high speeds putting it on
a disastrous Collision Course with a nearby Town
well disastrous if you work for the SCP Foundation
totally awesome for the rest of us the thing about
a ride on scp-2183 is that you really get your
money's worth when people nicknamed this thing
the ride never ends they don't just do that for
fun this ride literally never ends over the first
few weeks of the rider's ride the foundation
just tried to suppress news of sightings from
spreading multiple people around the nearest
Idaho towns reported seeing a Flying Roller
Coaster cart zipping around the sky thankfully
for the kill joys of the world that kind kind
of thing is easily written off as a trick of the
mind but this didn't stop the writer's epic Thrill
Ride from tearing it up all across Idaho over the
next few months this party train really hit the
road metaphorically speaking of course this card
constantly remained 120 to 150 meters above the
ground and kept traveling at consistent speeds of
over 200 kilometers an hour that makes it roughly
tied for the second fastest roller coaster in the
world the people lucky enough to spot this bad
boy in action reported that they heard a panicked
terrifying screaming coming from inside the card
as it passed that's how you know that the rider
was having a hell of a time in there real shame
that anyone who spotted it got a big old dose
of Class A amnestics from the killjoy Brigade
speaking of those squares the SCP Foundation
tried multiple times to stop the ride and save
the rider from this awesome experience they sent
in helicopters and lowered ladders down to him
but the rider perhaps finally appreciating what
a gift he was given here kept his arms fastened
to his sides his face forced into a permanent
Grimace nobody knew how he could still be alive
despite having no food or water in all this
time we can only guess it's because scp-2183
is just that awesome anytime these Foundation
dweebs try to get near the card it immediately
undertook evasive maneuvers and got the hell out
of there nobody could bring this ultimate ride
to an end in the end the SCP Foundation proved
they could take being anti-fun to straight up
military proportions they approved firing a
missile at this piece of coaster dream Tech
hoping to finally bring its awesomeness to an end
after making a valiant effort to avoid them the
missile eventually struck the cart they thought
the rider inside was dead but the cart kept flying
for another four years before finally crashing 34
kilometers from the rest of the ride relatively
unscathed probably after crashing into one of
those beefy Idaho pigeons and as the foundation
would soon find out the writer was still around
2 do he just wasn't in the card anymore nope he
was suspended in the air in a seated position
124 meters above the crash cards we call him
the rider cause he's still riding to this very
day and if anyone comes within a 50 meter radius
of him in any direction he'll just fly away
until he's alone again we don't know about you
but we think the Riders whole permanent flying
situation isn't a horrific Purgatory of eternal
torment if he's alive under his comatose state
it's actually the ultimate ride and really what
more could you want out of life right sometimes
people working on the site see him sitting in
the cars often only for a split second he's one
with the coaster now total Nirvana like we said
before kids the ride never ends now go check
out a sea snails fantasy scp-1867 a gentleman
an scp-1594 Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse for
more interesting safe class scps totally radical